Sie wussten alles über mich. Sie wussten, sie wussten was ich esse, was ich trinke, welche Filme ich mag. Sie wussten, sie wussten, woher ich komme, welche Zigaretten ich früher geraucht habe. Und alles was sie wissen, wissen sie, wissen sie, haben sie aus dem Internet. Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, über meine Kreditkarten. Unser ganzes Leben läuft über Computer und sie wussten. Sie können mich einfach verschwenden lassen. Niemand würde es kümmern, niemand würde es verstehen. Kein Harm würde mehr nach mir krähen.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 106. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu einer neuen Sendung hier on the road. Chaosradio Express ist mal wieder unterwegs und hat die von euch so toll gesponserte Bahncard zum Einsatz gebracht. Und der Weg führt mich jetzt nach, die mich in der letzten Sendung ja schon bis Oldenburg vorgedrungen war, nach Ostfriesland. In der Gegend von Lea sind wir hier in der unendlichen Weite. Es stürmt und braust, wie man es hier so erwarten möchte. Und ja, ich bin zu Gast bei Holger Buss und Ingo Busker. Hallo Holger. Hallo Ingo. Ja, ja, der Grund, warum ich hier bin, ist euer Projekt. Das Projekt ist bekannt unter dem Namen Mikrokopter. Vielleicht könnt ihr mal ganz kurz sagen, was das Projekt betrifft.
Ja, also ein Mikrokopter ist ein Quadrokopter, was vielleicht schon einige Leute kennen oder schon mal gehört haben. Der zeichnet sich dadurch aus, also es ist erstmal ein sehr krechstaatendes Fluggerät, um das mal vorweg zu sagen. Der zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass er vier Propeller hat, auf vier Motoren, und die sind kreuzförmig angeordnet. Und alle Propeller drücken den Luftstrom gleichförmig nach unten.
Und so fliegt er.
Ja, also im Prinzip.
Ich wollte erst mal einen kleinen Überblick geben. Das heißt, diese Dinger sind ja wohl bekannt. Also wer vor allem in den letzten Jahren auf dem Chaos-Communication-Kongress aufgelaufen ist, oder vielleicht auch bei anderen Veranstaltungen, wird sie sicherlich schon mal gesehen haben. Das sind diese kleinen, bießigen, fixen Maschinen, die einem immer um die Ohren fliegen und dabei auch noch so einen ganz kernigen Sound von sich geben. Ja, ihr beide habt dieses Projekt in Angriff genommen. Wann ging das los?
Wir haben Ende 2006 damit angefangen.
Und was war der Grund?
Wir haben durch Zufall mal eine Mikrodrohne gesehen. Das ist ein kommerzielles Produkt von einem Quadrocopter. Und waren sofort von dem Grundprinzip angetan. Also dieser simple Aufbau.
Wo habt ihr den gesehen?
Ein Kollege von uns hatte so ein Ding. Und den haben wir uns mal angeguckt.
Die sind nicht ganz billig, oder?
Nee, richtig. Also die sind nicht ganz billig.
Und wofür hat er den so verwendet? War das dann nur so aus Spaß und Freude?
Ja, er macht Luftbilder. Und dafür taugt die Dinger ganz gut. Ja, genau.
Richtig.
Und da haben wir halt dieses Modell mal gesehen. Es gab es halt allerdings auch schon vorher als Spielzeug in Spielzeugausgaben mit Gleichstrommotoren. Und das Verblüffende daran war halt, dass dieses Funktionsprinzip relativ einfach ist und der mechanische Aufbau relativ einfach. Also man muss sich nicht weiter mit Aerodynamik auseinandersetzen, so wie zum Beispiel bei Flächenfliegern. Und das hat uns Elektrotechniker einfach angesprochen.
Genau, jetzt wollte ich mich gerade fragen, was euer Hintergrund ist. Seid ihr auch schon so Flugnarren gewesen? Oder was sind so eure Hintergründe?
Nein, also wir kommen, wir sind eigentlich Elektrotechniker. Das heißt, wir haben Elektrotechnik studiert, Technische Informatik in der Fachrichtung. Und haben mit Modellbau eigentlich überhaupt nichts am Hut gehabt. Vorher auch noch nie irgendwas in der Luft gehabt. Und uns interessierte halt der elektronische Teil auch sehr. Und wir hatten damals mal so ein bisschen hinterfragt bei diesem Kollegen. Und das klang alles sehr kompliziert, was da drin ist an Elektronik. Alles sehr hochtrabend. Und da haben wir dann gesagt, probieren wir das mal mit unseren Hausmitteln, was wir so haben, was wir so kennen. Ob man das nicht auch einfacher machen kann. Und vor allen Dingen deutlich günstiger.
Und dann habt ihr euch, also das gilt jetzt auch für dich sozusagen. Also ihr habt da beide sozusagen den gleichen Hintergrund.
Genau. Also als wir das Gerät damals gesehen hatten, hatten wir noch gar nicht daran gedacht, sowas auch selber mal zu bauen. Weil es wirkte auf uns anfangs recht kompliziert. Und auch mit sehr komplizierter Sensorik und Algorithmen. Und also von daher war ursprünglich der Gedanke gar nicht, das selber zu bauen. Aber die Idee ist irgendwie in unseren Köpfen gereift, sodass wir uns mal Gedanken darüber gemacht haben, wie funktioniert sowas überhaupt? Wie werden die Motoren angesteuert? Also wie können die Algorithmen ablaufen? Und dann irgendwann haben wir uns zusammen gesetzt und haben gesagt, weißt was, wir bestellen jetzt mal Motoren und Propeller. Und dann haben wir angefangen.
Also ich meine, jeder kennt ja natürlich den Hubschrauber. Da ist dann so ein Propeller und einer ist oben und einer ist hinten. Also zwei Propeller, um genau zu sein. Ich hatte übrigens auch schon mal eine ganz lustige Sendung über Hubschrauber, vielmehr eigentlich über Hubschrauber-Kultur, hier bei Chaosradio Express. Wer sozusagen mehr über Hubschrauber erfahren will, sollte vielleicht da noch mal reinhören. Aber das Besondere an den Quadrocoptern ist ja, wie dein Name schon sagt, wie du auch schon erwähnt hast, dass es eben vier sind. Was ist der eigentliche Grund dafür, dass es vier sind?
Man braucht zwei linksläufige und zwei rechtsläufige Propeller.
Das heißt, die drehen sich in unterschiedliche Richtungen.
Genau. Das machen die deshalb, weil ein Propeller erzeugt nicht nur Schub als Luftdruck nach unten, sondern auch einen Drehmoment. Und wenn ich zwei linksläufige habe und zwei rechtsläufige, dann kann ich das Drehmoment damit kompensieren.
Sofern die sich gleich schnell drehen?
Ja, so ist es.
Beim Hubschrauber wird das zum Beispiel durch den Heckrotor gemacht, weil der hat ja einen großen Hauptrotor und der erzeugt ja auch einen Drehmoment. Und da wird das Drehmoment ausgeglichen durch den Heckrotor.
Der dann einfach entgegenblästet sozusagen.
Und dadurch, dass ich halt vier Motoren habe, die an jedem Ausleger sitzen, kann ich halt das Fluggerät auch in alle Richtungen neigen.
Genau, das mit dem Ausleger, also für die, die jetzt sozusagen so ein Ding noch nicht gesehen haben, sollte man noch mal kurz hier beschreiben, wie das eigentlich aussieht. Im Wesentlichen ist das einfach so ein Kreuz. Ich vermute mal, das sind so Aluschienen, die dann einfach zusammengebaut werden. In der Mitte, wo die sich treffen, da sitzt dann die ganze Steuerelektronik. Und an den Enden sind eben die Rotoren angebracht, die sind einfach draufgeschraubt wahrscheinlich. Und ich nehme an, immer die gegenüberliegenden haben dann auch die gleiche Laufrichtung. Okay. Und, wovon habe ich dich gerade unterbrochen? Wie auch immer. Also das ist sozusagen das Setup. Und wenn man jetzt alle gleichzeitig laufen lässt, dann fliegt das Ding einfach nach oben.
Ja, also man könnte sich zum Beispiel vorstellen, man stellt das Gerät auf den Boden und hätte jetzt keine Regelelektronik und würde alle Propeller idealerweise gleich laufen lassen. Dann müsste das zwangsläufig senkrecht in die Luft steigen.
Wenn jetzt so eine gewisse Grundkraft sozusagen erst mal erreicht ist, Ja, richtig.
Also unter idealen Bedingungen würde das Ding senkrecht nach oben steigen.
Was wiegt so ein Quadrocopter, wie ihr ihn baut?
Der wiegt so knapp einen Kilo, zwischen einem halben und einem Kilo.
Und was für Drehzahlen müssen da jetzt erst mal erreicht werden, bevor sich das Ding dann hebt?
Also die Propeller, die laufen so mit 5.000 bis 10.000 Umdrehungen.
Oha, das ist schon fix. Und bei 5.000 geht es schon los, sozusagen.
Ja, das geht wahrscheinlich auch schon früher los. Es hängt ein bisschen von der Aerodynamik des Propellers ab. Und wenn halt Schwebegas produziert wird, dann hebt er halt ab.
Schwebegas heißt was?
Also dann ist der Impuls von den Motoren genauso groß wie der Impuls der Gewichtskraft.
Also dass er sozusagen schwebt. Also im Sinne von Gaspedal, also sozusagen so viel Power, wie man irgendwie braucht, um das Ding einfach in der Luft zu halten. So, das heißt, die ganze Flugphysik basiert im Prinzip da drauf, dass die Dinger sich gegenseitig stabilisieren. Das heißt, das Ding klebt eigentlich im Idealzustand, in diesem Schwebegaszustand einfach wie so ein Punkt einfach mitten in der Luft, wie so ein Ballon, der gerade nicht mehr schnarrt. Ja, genau.
Nun ist es natürlich so, dass es ideale Zustände nicht gibt. Und dann kommt die Elektronik ins Spiel. Die misst genau die aktuelle Lage des Mikrokopters und steuert dann halt die Motoren so geschickt an, dass sich immer die gewünschte Lage einstellt. Also gegebenenfalls durch eine Luftverwirbelung oder sowas würde das Gerät um, sagen wir mal, einen Grad nach vorne kippen. Dann misst die Elektronik das schon und kompensiert das. Dadurch würde der vordere Motor etwas mehr Schub kriegen oder der hintere Motor vielleicht etwas weniger Schub. Und dadurch dreht er sich halt ganz leicht wieder zurück.
Das heißt, wenn irgendwie ein Luftschuss kommt und irgendwie den einen Arm nach oben drückt, dann kann die Sensorik das bemerken, wo bemerkt ist, und lässt dann denjenigen, der nach unten gedrückt wird, einfach stärker rotieren.
Richtig. Im Gegenzug muss natürlich der Vorderen der Vorderung um denselben Wert gesenkt werden. Weil ansonsten würde ich den Gesamtdrehimpuls wieder durcheinander bringen und das Ding würde anfangen zu gieren. Also würde sich auf der Stelle drehen. Also es muss in dem Fall immer der Vorderer um denselben Faktor langsamer werden als der hintere. Und die Lagelektronik löst die Winkel in etwa 1.000 Grad auf. Und die läuft mit 500 Hertz. Also 500 Mal pro Sekunde wird der Winkel berechnet und halt die Motoren kriegen einen neuen Sollwert. Und das macht es halt möglich, das Ding so stabil in die Luft zu kriegen.
Wenn man das mal ausprobiert, wenn so ein Teil neben einem fliegt, merkt man ja, wenn man das Ding so anschubst, dann ist einfach diese Ausgleichsbewegung ist einfach instantan. Also es geht ja wie so eine Katze, irgendwie faucht es einfach sofort zurück und hält sich einfach drin. Aber wie fliegt man denn damit jetzt? Ich meine, wenn er die ganze Zeit stabil in der Mitte hängt, dann hängt er ja immer nur am gleichen Punkt. Also was führt jetzt in der Flugphysik dazu, dass man damit auch irgendwo hinfliegen kann?
Ja, wir haben ja einen Modellbausender, das heißt, die Steuerung läuft über einen handelsüblichen Modellbausender. Und da kann man zum Beispiel, wenn man nach vorne fliegen will, das heißt nicken, wir bezeichnen das als nicken, dann wird einfach der hintere Propeller beschleunigt, der vordere halt läuft langsamer. Dadurch neigt sich das Fluggerät nach vorne und die fliegt nach vorne.
Das heißt, diese Neigung wird bewusst auf einen bestimmten Winkel gehalten. Und umso größer dieser Winkel ist, umso schneller fliegt er?
So weiter geht er nach vorne, das ist richtig.
Wie weit kann man das so treiben? Also bestimmt nicht mehr 90 Grad, oder?
Man kann im Prinzip bis 90 Grad, aber dort hat man natürlich keinen Auftrieb mehr. Das heißt, er sackt natürlich mit Erdbeschleunigung.
Verstehe.
Macht nicht viel Sinn.
Aber so 45 Grad ist...
Das ist durchaus möglich, ja.
Was ist so der ideale, weiß ich nicht, also wie kommt man am schnellsten voran? Wie viel Grad muss er sich dann...
Also wenn ich fliege und ich will jetzt schnell nach vorne, dann drehe ich ihn kurzzeitig um 90 Grad nach vorne. Also ich kriege dann einen gewaltigen Schub nach vorne. Und dann kompensiere ich das wieder, also stelle ihn wieder mehr oder weniger senkrecht, also waagerecht. Und dann hat er schon mal die Vorwärtsbewegung. Und wenn man jetzt nicht... also in moderat neigt...
Also du erzeugst sozusagen kurzzeitig so einen Bewegungsimpuls nach vorne, gehst dann gleich wieder horizontal und nimmst einfach sozusagen diese Acceleration einfach mit.
Richtig, das würde schon reichen. Man kann allerdings auch den Stick von der Fernbedienung einfach nur, sagen wir mal, zwei Grad nach vorne bewegen. Dadurch bewegt er sich ganz gemächlich nach vorne und bewegt sich dann halt in die Richtung.
Handelsübliche Fernbedienung, hast du gesagt, Ingo. Was heißt das? Also wie, was für ein Handel muss ich da gehen, damit das üblich ist?
Modellbauhandel. Also wenn man in einem Modellbau-Fachgeschäft geht und man möchte eine Fernbedienung haben, also einen Sender für ein Modellfluggerät zum Beispiel, dann geht das. Die laufen für gewöhnlich auf 35 Megahertz. Und wir haben halt einen Empfänger drin. Das sind halt Standardkomponenten aus dem Modellbaubereich. Das macht es halt schon einfacher.
Also eine ganz normale, analoge Kommunikation. Das heißt, wenn man irgendwie mal mit seinem Quadrocopter auf der Wiese sieht, dann kann man dann auch mit einer handelsüblichen Fernbedienung dann seinen Copter übernehmen.
Und wenn man die richtige Frequenz treffen würde, den richtigen Kanal einstellt, dann hast du da sehr große Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das geht.
Ja, also ich sage mal so, wenn man jetzt einen zweiten Sender auf dem selben Kanal anmacht, dann hat man normalerweise den Effekt, dass sich beide Frequenzen so mischen, dass der Empfänger nichts Anständiges mehr empfängt, weil ja der andere Sender auch noch im Betrieb ist. Und der Mikro…
Es sei denn, man ist sehr viel stärker, oder?
Ja, wenn man jetzt die Empfangsstufe so weit drosselt, dass man nur noch den einen Kanal dadurch kriegt, wäre es im Prinzip möglich, das Ding dann zu kidnappen, falls du darauf ansprichst.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja so ein Szenario. Ich meine, gerade so diese Mikro-Drohensysteme, die du da angesprochen hast, die werden ja auch wirklich genutzt, auch bei Law-Enforcement-Behörden zum Beispiel, das sind ja auch so optimale Überwachungsgeräte mit Kameras bestückt. Da kann man sich schon fragen, wer alles so in der Lage ist, das Ding so durch die Gegend zu fliegen. Na ja, gut, darauf wollte ich jetzt gar nicht so sehr zu sprechen kommen. Diese Fernbedienung, damit steuert man sozusagen alles. Aber was muss man denn alles steuern können, um das Ding in voller Kontrolle zu haben? Also die Neigung? Es gibt auch einen vorne. Obwohl das Ding ja im Prinzip, wenn man so draufschaut, kein wirkliches vorne und hinten hat, es gibt einen vorne.
Ja, es ist symmetrisch aufgebaut. Das heißt, optisch gibt es keinen vorne, aber wir haben einen dieser Ausleger, markieren wir halt als vorne. Darauf beziehen sich die Bewegungen von der Fernbedienung. Das heißt, wenn ich meinen Steuerknüppel nach vorne bewege, dann neigt er sich in den Richtung von diesem markierten Ausleger.
Steuerknüppel gibt es da zwei.
Genau, ich habe einen Steuerknüppel, mit dem kann ich nach vorne und hinten, also vorne, hinten, links, rechts.
Das ist die Neige.
Nick und Roll.
Okay, das heißt, auch wenn ich nach links fliege, dann das gleiche Prinzip. Das heißt, dann kippt er einfach nach links ab.
Genau.
Dann ist ja genau dasselbe. Okay, ich verstehe.
Dann habe ich einen anderen Steuerknüppel, damit kann ich das Gas vorgeben. Das heißt halt Gas, darum vorhin auch Schwebegas. Das ist im Prinzip die Geschwindigkeit der Motoren. Und ich kann auf der Stelle drehen, das heißt gieren.
Gieren, also sozusagen um die Homenachse drehen. In sich rotieren.
Wie beim Holikopter auch, der Heckrotor.
Achso, das heißt da nutzt man dann sozusagen diesen Effekt, der vorhin sozusagen eigentlich erst mal ausgeglichen gehört, dass man die Rotation der beiden Linkstrehenden sozusagen runterfährt und dann dreht er sich nach rechts.
Genau.
Eigentlich alles ganz logisch, ne?
Ja, wie gesagt, das Prinzip ist trivial mehr oder weniger. Das Funktionsprinzip ist doch schon seit über 100 Jahren bekannt. Und weil es halt dementsprechend einfach ist. Nur die heutige Motorik und Sensorik und Elektronik, die macht es jetzt halt erst möglich, dass man das auch wirklich gesteuert bekommt. Die Dinge anständig umzusetzen. Genau.
Weil man muss halt permanent das machen. Gab es denn schon mal so vier Rotorsysteme, sagen wir mal so large scale, so als Hochschrauberkonzept?
Ja, also in den 20er Jahren gab es schon die ersten flugfähigen Geräte. Die funktionierten mit mechanischen Kreiseln. Und in den 60er Jahren haben die Amerikaner da auch schon Experimente mitgemacht. Die haben richtig bemannte Fluggeräte damit gehabt.
Aber das war wahrscheinlich alles zu kompliziert, zu teuer, zu aufwendig, nicht zuverlässig, weiß ich nicht.
Woran es jetzt letztendlich gescheitert ist, weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht war es einfach, dass der eindrothorige Helikopter vom Prinzip her so viel einfacher war, weil er halt nur eine Antriebsmaschine hat, und dass sich das halt für den manntragenden Betrieb durchgesetzt hat.
Auch wenn natürlich die Steuerung eines solchen Helikopters ungleich komplizierter ist.
Ja gut, also wenn man jetzt einen riesigen Helikopter hat, manntragend, da ist wahrscheinlich das Handling über die Taumelscheibe, also über die Blattverstellung wesentlich einfacher als im kleinen Maßstab. Weil so ein großer Helikopter vielleicht auch nicht so schnell irgendwo aneckt, wie jetzt bei unseren kleinen Modellen.
Wie hoch könnt ihr eigentlich fliegen?
Soweit der Sender reicht.
Das ist so dem Ding egal. Also wenn der Sender weit genug, dann geht er so, bis keine Luft mehr gibt.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Und wie schnell ist das Gerät?
Einer bei uns aus dem Forum hat mal eine Geschwindigkeitsmessung gemacht mit dem GPS und die sind auf 95 kmh gekommen.
95 Stundenkilometer?
Ja, genau.
Jetzt nur nach oben oder auch nach vorne?
Nein, nur nach vorne. Also der ist natürlich erst auf Höhe gegangen, hat das Ding mehr oder weniger 90 Grad nach vorne geneigt und ist damit quasi voll Power.
Hat den Sprung mitgenommen. Genau.
Ist er dann schneller als im Steigflug?
Aber wir haben auch schon so 75 kmh im normalen Flug, haben wir auch schon gemessen.
Es ist auch Spaß, mal mit dem Auto nebenher gefahren. Einer saß auf dem Beifahrersitz und hat das Ding gesteuert. Und dann sind wir auf der Landstraße gefahren und hatten das Ding neben mir.
Du hast ja auch ein kleines Vögelchen dabei, was irgendwie immer...
Ja, genau.
Ja, der eine mag Katzen und Hunde und andere lassen Quadrocopter hinter sich herfliegen.
Ja, genau, das geht ganz gut. Das geht auch, das geht sogar auf dem Fahrrad, wenn man freihändig fährt und man fliegt immer mit dem Quadrocopter vor sich her. Das geht auch.
Okay, jetzt ist, was wir noch nicht so richtig erwähnt haben, in der Mitte prangt ja die ganze Elektronik. Und du hast ja schon gesagt, wenn, ja, um das Ding wirklich in Kontrolle halten zu lassen, muss man die ganze Zeit diese Sensoren überprüfen. Also man muss verschiedene Flugparameter überprüfen, um überhaupt erst mal diese Stabilität hinzubekommen. Wie misst man denn das, was man jetzt, also was gibt es da überhaupt für eine Sensorik und wie weit ist die relevant für den Flug?
Der Hauptlage-Regler, wir nennen die Platine Flight Control, die ist mit verschiedenen Sensoren bestückt. Es sind dreiachsige Beschleunigungs-Sensoren da drauf.
Also dieses typische X, Y und Z, was man mittlerweile fast in jedem Info hat.
Genau, der misst damit Beschleunigung. Die Hauptidee von diesem Beschleunigungs-Sensor ist, wie eine elektronische Wasserwaage zu arbeiten. Das heißt, der misst hauptsächlich die Erdbeschleunigung, die man nach unten zeigt. Also wenn das Ding jetzt hier auf dem Tisch steht, dann misst es eine Beschleunigung, auch wenn ich das Gerät nicht bewege, und zwar immer die Erdbeschleunigung, die quasi in Richtung Boden zeigt. Und dazu kommen noch drei Drehratensensoren, sogenannte Gyroskope, die messen die Drehrate der Bewegung. Das heißt, das sind elektronische Bauteile, die haben mechanisch aufgehängte Teile da drin und die sind in Bewegung, die werden in Schwingungen gebracht und die nutzen den Coriolis-Effekt.
Das heißt, wenn es sich um sie herum dreht, dann dreht sich das, was innen angetrieben wird, anders?
Ja, es wird ein Teil in Schwingungen gebracht und in dem Moment, wo es sich dreht, entsteht in eine bestimmte Richtung eine Kraft und diese Kraft wird halt gemessen. Das nennt sich die Coriolis-Kraft. Muss man mal ins Physikbuch gucken, um das nochmal nachzulesen, gegebenenfalls. Und diese Kraft wird halt gemessen von diesen Sensoren und dadurch kann es genau die Drehgeschwindigkeit messen.
Das heißt, was ihr wisst, ist einerseits, wie sich das gesamte Gerät gerade bewegt, relativ zur Erdbeschleunigung und ihr wisst, wie es sich in sich relativ zu seinem Ursprung in der Mitte dreht.
Ja, richtig.
Aber diese Drehgeschichte ist nicht dreidimensional, sondern das ist nur…
Doch, das ist dreidimensional. Auch dreidimensional. In alle drei Achsen wird die Drehgeschwindigkeit messen.
Okay, alles klar, also in alle drei Achsen wird Beschleunigung, in alle drei Achsen wird die Drehgeschichte gemessen. Das auch mit diesen 500 Hertz, die du erwähnt hast.
Und man braucht diese Sensorik, dass man halt drei Drehratensensoren hat und drei Beschleunigungssensoren, weil die Messergebnisse so miteinander verrechnet werden müssen, dass man abschätzen kann, wo ist zur Zeit unten. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel nur den Beschleunigungssensor benutzen würde, dann würde das theoretisch hier auf dem Tisch funktionieren, weil der Beschleunigungssensor ganz gut liefert, wo ist jetzt unten. Aber man darf nicht vergessen, dass das Fluggerät ja auch in Bewegung ist. Das heißt, wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Kreis fliege, dann zeigt der Beschleunigungssensor eine Zeit lang halt nicht nach unten, sondern quasi in Kreisfluchtrichtung auch nach außen. Und dann wüsste die Flight-Control natürlich nicht mehr, wo ist jetzt eigentlich wirklich unten. Und dafür braucht man halt die Drehratensensoren, die messen, wie ist eigentlich die tatsächliche Bewegung gewesen. Die integrieren diese Bewegung auf und schätzen anhand der Drehraten wieder die aktuelle Richtung, wo gegebenenfalls unten sein könnte. Und das wird dann wieder gestützt mit dem Wert aus dieser elektronischen Wasserwaage, also dem Beschleunigungssensor. Und anhand dessen schätzt die gesamte Elektronik ab ständig, wo es gerade unten ist.
Aha, das heißt, der Wert, die Beschleunigung selber, ist nicht unbedingt immer was wert, aber man braucht sie aber auch immer. Also auch nur mit dem Büro wüsste man jetzt auch nicht, was Sache ist.
Dann weiß man nicht, wo unten ist. Also man könnte grundsätzlich damit fliegen. Also zum Beispiel, dann hätte man bloß den Effekt wie beim Helikopter. Beim Helikopter ist das so, wenn ich den Störgschiff nach vorne bewege, dann neigt sich die rote Achse nach vorne. Und wenn ich ihn wieder gerade stellen will, muss ich ihn wieder nach hinten ziehen. Bei uns ist das so, dass die neutrale Position, das heißt, wenn ich keinen Steuerknüppel bewege, immer gerade unten ist. Und darum interessiert uns sehr, wo unten ist. Und das machen wir halt über diese Beschleunigungssensoren. Das heißt also, ich bewege meinen Knüppel nach vorne, er neigt sich nach vorne. Ich lasse ihn wieder in die neutrale Position. Beim Helikopter würde er jetzt einfach weiter fliegen. Unser richtet sich aber wieder gerade, gerade, stellt sich wieder gerade neutral hin. Das ist der große Unterschied. Das macht es aber auch verhältnismäßig einfach zu fliegen. Weil beim Helikopter muss ich ständig im Prinzip den Steuerknüppel bewegen, weil ich immer die Bewegung ausgleichen muss. Und bei uns muss ich im Prinzip nur loslassen und ich habe wieder neutral.
Aber dazu muss man wissen, wo unten ist, damit man sich sozusagen wieder leigen kann. Und unten heißt sozusagen, rausfinden, wo die Gravitation saugt.
Ja, im Prinzip wohl. Also im Prinzip die elektronische Wasserwaage, die ich vorhin schon...
Jaja, genau. Aber das ist ja sozusagen der Grundwert. Wenn sozusagen alles neutral ist, dann kommt irgendwo ein Geh her und das sieht man dann.
Genau.
Und das mit diesem Ausgleich ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar geworden. Also wenn ich jetzt einen Kreis fliege, dann habe ich Fliehkräfte.
Das ist etwas von meins.
Und die sieht man auch im Beschleunigungs-Sensor.
Richtig.
Weil die dann wie Gravitation wirken.
Genau. Also ich kann das nicht auseinanderhalten. Echte Beschleunigung und Erdbeschleunigung, das kann man am Messwert nicht sehen. Und dann müssen halt ständig diese Werte miteinander verglichen werden. Und dann wird halt geschätzt, wer von diesen Sensoren liefert das bestmögliche Ergebnis. Und so werden unter Umständen die Sensoren, zum Beispiel wird dann die Gewichtung des Beschleunigungs-Sensors zurückgenommen. Und dann sagt man einfach, jetzt stütze ich mich halt mehr auf die Gyros, also auf die Drehratensensoren. Andererseits, wenn das Fluggerät einigermaßen ruhig in der Luft liegt, weiß man, dass der Beschleunigungs-Sensor einen relativ guten Wert liefert. Und dadurch wird halt der Beschleunigungs-Sensor wieder stärker gewichtet.
Das heißt, umso mehr die Gyroskope sozusagen an Drehbewegungen melden, umso weniger kann man dem Beschleunigungs-Sensor vertrauen.
Ja, im Prinzip ist das so.
Und gibt es auch so, ich meine, funktionieren diese Sensoren auch immer zuverlässig? Also sind die so gut, wie man es braucht?
Die Sensoren funktionieren grundsätzlich ganz zuverlässig. Die haben nur einen entscheidenden Nachteil und das ist Temperaturdrift. Die Sensoren, die driften alle unterschiedlich stark. Und die Algorithmen versuchen halt auch, die aktuelle Drift, die zurzeit herrscht, zu berechnen und abzuschätzen und wieder zu kompensieren.
Was machst du mit Drift genau?
Wenn ich zum Beispiel von Temperaturdrift rede, dann ist es so, wenn ich jetzt meinen Mikrokopter in den Backofen stelle und ihn um 50 Grad erwärme, dann laufen mir die Messwerte weg. Das heißt, die Messwerte liefern mir zum Beispiel eine Drehrate von, sagen wir mal, drei Grad pro Sekunde. Wenn ich mich dann nur auf diese drei Grad pro Sekunde stützen würde, dann würde das Ding zwangsläufig nach zehn Sekunden um 30 Grad schiefstehen. Und die Elektronik bzw. die Software, die misst ja alle Sensordaten und kann aber jetzt abschätzen, dass der Beschleunigungssensor jetzt gesagt hat, ich habe mich aber nicht gedreht. Der Gyro meint aber, er würde sich beharrlich drehen, eben durch diese Temperatur drift. Und dann schätzt die Software ab, wie stark driftet denn jetzt mein Gyroskop zurzeit.
Das heißt, die korrigieren sich einfach nur auf Basis ihrer laufenden Werte Normalität. Ihr habt keinen Temperatursensor drin und sagt, oh Gott, sind sie auf 50 Grad. Da stimmt wieder bestimmt nichts. Sondern es ist einfach nur mehr so eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung fast schon.
Ja, es ist ja so, dass die Sensoren an sich redundant sind. Das heißt, ich habe ja drei Beschleunigungssensoren und drei Drehratensensoren, und die müssen ja im Prinzip alle dasselbe anzeigen.
Also du hast von jedem, meinst du jetzt die x, y und z?
Nein, nein.
Oder meinst du, du hast alles mal drei? Also hast du dreimal x, y und z, oder meinst du, du hast x, y und z?
Nein, also ich habe drei Drehratensensoren und drei Beschleunigungssensoren. Die benutze ich ja alle dazu, um einen Wert festzustellen. Und zwar, wo unten ist. Im Prinzip könnten ja alleine drei Beschleunigungssensoren das machen oder alleine drei Drehratensensoren. Ich habe aber ja nun die doppelte Anzahl, also eine gewisse Redundanz. Und genau das ermöglicht es mir, Drift abzuschätzen.
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen die eigentliche Ingenieursleistung am Anfang gewesen, um das Ding überhaupt erst mal stabil in der Luft zu kriegen.
Ja, unter anderem.
Wir konnten ja auch nicht fliegen, das darf man auch nicht vergessen. Wir sind ja sehr blind an die Sache rangegangen. Wir haben ein Fluggerät gebaut, haben das Software programmiert, sicherlich mit dem einen oder anderen Bug. Und wir konnten auch nicht fliegen. Das heißt, das war am Anfang sehr interessant. Liegt es jetzt daran, dass wir wirklich nicht fliegen können? Oder liegt es daran, dass wir einfach falsch programmiert haben?
Ihr habt ja so an den Regeln gezogen, das Ding hat sich nicht geneigt.
Aber dann war dann plötzlich ein Busch im Weg und dann war der Busch, dann war der Flug ziemlich kurz.
Da spart man sich die Heckenschere.
Ja, genau.
Und? Das war dann einfach nur so mühsame Kleinarbeit und ein Bugsinn.
Am Anfang sind wir angefangen und haben auch nicht draußen...
Habt ihr denn damit gerechnet, dass ihr so einen Sensorenabgleich machen müsst? War das schon von Anfang an klar?
Nein, das hat sich alles zuerst ergeben. Also wir haben ganz blauäugig angefangen und haben gesagt, komm, so müsste das eigentlich funktionieren. Und unsere erste Herausforderung war zum Beispiel, den Drehzahlsteller für die Motoren zu entwickeln, weil das sind ja im Prinzip Wechselstrommotoren, die brauchen also ein Drehfeld von außen und nicht nur eine Gleichspannung, und dann drehen sie los, sondern die brauchen halt einen sogenannten Brushless-Regler. Das sind der Brushless-Motoren. Und den mussten wir ganz zuerst entwickeln, weil es halt am Markt keinen gab, der unseren Ansprüchen genügte.
Aber was war mit den anderen?
Die Normalen, die es im Modellbau gibt, die werden mit 50 Hz Update-Rate gefahren und sind halt dafür gebaut, dass man zum Beispiel ein Flugzeug damit antreibt. Man hat also sehr langsame Drehzahländerung.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
Das hängt halt damit zusammen, dass der Benutzer normalerweise ganz langsam nur sein Gaststick bewegt.
Aber da ihr ja im Prinzip mit 500 Hz Korrekturen anbringen wollt, könntet ihr ja nur jeden zehnten Wert sozusagen da wirklich umgesetzt wissen.
Richtig und die Dinger wären viel zu träge gewesen, das wäre also gar nicht gegangen. Und dann haben wir halt zunächst diesen Fraschless-Regler entwickelt und der dann halt exakt das machte, wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben. Und das war halt eine der ersten Hürden, die wir überhaupt nehmen mussten.
Das heißt, an der Stelle konntet ihr auch eure Elektrotechnik-Expertise gleich voll zum Einsatz bringen?
Ja, genau.
Heißt, entwickeln, dass ihr da jetzt noch ein fertiges Bauteil genommen habt und das nur anders gesteuert habt oder habt ihr da wirklich was gebaut?
Nein, wir haben mal so einen Schaltplan gezeichnet, Platiniger Edged, Teile draufgelötet, Software programmiert und dann ging es los.
Okay, also im Wesentlichen ging es nur darum zu regeln, wie der Strom zum Motor kommt und wie häufig er sozusagen in Rotation gebracht wird.
Ja, so ganz grob kann man das so sagen. Also es ist so der Brushless-Regler, der bestromt den Motor, dadurch dreht der Motor sich ein ganz kleines Stück und dann wird die Spannung, die der Motor erzeugt, dadurch, dass er sich dreht, wird wieder gemessen und anhand der gemessenen Spannung wird entschieden, wann der Motor sich so weit gedreht hat, dass auf die nächste Phase geschaltet werden kann. Also es wird die Rotorlage geschätzt und dadurch halt die sogenannte Kommertierung, das nennt man das, wenn von einer Phase auf die andere geschaltet wird, wird dadurch gesteuert.
Und diese Motorsteuerung, die kommt jetzt auch immer noch zum Einsatz oder gibt es mittlerweile solche Dinge auch fertig zu kaufen, die die entsprechenden Anforderungen entsprechen?
Ne, also wir nutzen noch unsere eigenen.
Aber die Motoren, das ist wiederum handelsüblich, dass fast so auch im Modellbau generell verwendet, also überhaupt denke ich, im Wesentlichen sind das alles Modellbau-Komponenten, kann man das jetzt sagen?
Ja, also Modellbau-Komponenten beschränkt sich eigentlich auf die Motoren und auf die Propeller und vielleicht noch der Akku. Na gut, der Sender und der Empfänger.
Das ist ein Lithium-Ionen-Akku? Also dann eben auch so wie im Modellbau verwendet jetzt keiner Notebook-Technik?
Richtig. Also es ist schon, das stimmt schon, das ist schon einiges aus dem Modellbau da drin.
Das sind ja jetzt aber nicht die einzigen Sensoren, die in dem Gerät verbaut sind. Ihr braucht ja, ihr müsst ja auch noch wissen, wo ihr seid im Z, oder? Also wie hoch ihr fliegt.
Ja, dafür haben wir da einen Luftdrucksensor drauf. Der misst den atmosphärischen Luftdruck. Und wenn sich die Höhe ändert, dann ändert sich dementsprechend auch der Luftdruck, weil je höher man steigt, desto niedriger ist der Luftdruck.
Wie häufig ändert sich so das? Ich meine 500 Hertz, das wird ja bestimmt nicht, oder?
Ja, also je nachdem, wie schnell sich das Ding nach oben und unten bewegt.
Ja, klar, wenn man die 100 km durch die Gegend jagt, dann okay, verstehe ich das.
Ja, wir messen den Luftdruck auch schon mit 100 Hertz. Man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass der Luftdruck auch sehr großen atmosphärischen Schwankungen unterlegen ist und die Propeller der Motoren erzeugen ein gewisses Rauschen. Das muss natürlich alles geglättet werden.
Weil die ja sozusagen die ganze Zeit auf die Luft trommeln und dadurch auch Druckveränderungen bringen.
Genau, richtig.
Wo ist denn dann der Sensor angebracht?
Der ist mitten auf der Hauptplatine.
Aber eigentlich ist er ja dann relativ weit weg von diesem...
Ja, also direkt unter einem Rotor würde es überhaupt nicht funktionieren. Also es ist im Prinzip die einzige Stelle, wo es funktioniert. Unter den Propellern geht es natürlich zwangsläufig nicht, weil ich darunter den Luftdruck der Propeller habe.
Ja, man sollte auch sehen, dass man den Sensor ein bisschen kapselt. Oder bei unserem Modell hier haben wir halt einen Deckel drauf. Das heißt, wenn die Propellerwind auf diesen Sensor drauf trifft, dann hätte man halt eine falsche Messung.
Okay, das ist also kein Regenschutz, sondern es geht da im Wesentlichen um den Luftdrucksensor. Da steckt jetzt noch so ein Strohhalm drin, hat das auch was damit zu tun oder ist das nur für die Antennen?
Nein, das ist das Antennenröhrchen.
Was soll ich da schon, das wäre jetzt dann so.
Ja, wir haben ja so ein Kabel, das ist die Empfangsantenne und die sollte man irgendwie nicht in die Propeller kriegen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und da bietet sich so ein Röhrchen ganz gut an.
Ja, zum Luftdruck nochmal. Ja, da muss man mal bedenken, der Luftdruck ändert sich natürlich nur sehr wenig, wenn ich das Gerät um einen Zentimeter bewege und die Auflösung, die ich habe, die liegt um ungefähr ein bis zwei Zentimeter, daran wird die Höhe aufgelöst. Und der absolute Luftdruck, den wir zurzeit immer in der Atmosphäre haben, der liegt etwa um den Faktor 800.000 Mal höher, als mein eigentliches Messignal, was ich messen will.
800.000 Mal?
Okay, wie meinst du das, also wir haben hier in der Atmosphäre etwa ein Bar Luftdruck, wenn ich das Ding aber um einen Zentimeter anhebe, dann ändert sich der Luftdruck nur um 1,2 Mikrobar und das ist natürlich extrem wenig.
Und das kann der ja nicht auflösen?
Doch.
Das kann der auflösen.
Also das machen wir halt durch so eine Trick-Beschaltung, um halt diesen Luftdrucksensor, dem halt dieses Mess-Signal rauszukitzeln.
Und du hast ja gesagt, es gibt atmosphärische Schwankungen, ist das jetzt eine Schwankung von Tag zu Tag oder ist das wirklich, dass in anderen Luftschichten dann auf einmal doch ein ganz anderer Luftdruck herrscht oder dass das sich mit dem Wetter innerhalb von 20 Minuten ändert, was für Schwankungen ist das ausgesetzt?
Ja, also mit dem Wetter hat man für gewöhnlich langsame Luftdruckänderungen, es sei denn, es zieht eine starke Wetterfront auf, zum Beispiel beim Gewitter hätte man sowas. Also beim Gewitter könnte es durchaus vorkommen, dass das Ding immer innerhalb von einer Minute, sagen wir mal, um 50 Meter steigen würde, ohne dass es das merken würde. Das ist aber nur extrem seltenes Wetterphänomen. Aber Luftdruckänderungen hätte man zum Beispiel auch ganz stark in Gebäuden. Wenn ich zum Beispiel in einer Halle fliege, in einer Turnhalle zum Beispiel, und es lässt jemand die Tür offen stehen und es drückt Wind von draußen drauf oder die Lüftungsanlage springt an oder so.
Dann ändert sich natürlich der Luftdruck.
Genau, dann ändert sich der Luftdruck und dadurch gibt es natürlich dann eine Höhenänderung.
Vor allem, wenn man dann so feine Unterscheidungen tatsächlich auch messen kann.
Ja, genau.
Und ich meine, dieser Luftdruck ist ja auch nur ein relativer Wert. Das heißt, man muss den ja auch in irgendeiner Form in Relation setzen. Ist das so, dass man dann beim Start sozusagen das Ding auf Null stellt und ab dann …Genau. Okay. Ist das dann so eine Taste, die ihr an der Fernbedienung dafür drücken musst?
Ja, das macht er selbst. Nach dem Einschalten misst er halt einmal den atmosphärischen Luftdruck und gleicht halt den Messverstärker ab von dem Luftdrucksensor und dann weiß er genau, hier ist jetzt Höhe Null und dann kann ich so losfliegen.
Wie genau kann man dann arbeiten mit der Höhe? Also ist es jetzt vorstellbar, dass das Gerät immer in einen Meter über der Erde fliegt?
Ja.
Das geht?
Das geht.
Und wenn dann so ein Busch kommt, dann rasselt er da rein?
Genau, da hängt er.
Genau, den sieht er ja nicht.
Ziemlich genau in einen Meter Höhe rasselt er da rein.
Da fehlt ja noch so ein Fledermaus-Sensor sozusagen. Habt ihr den auch drin?
Nee, jetzt nicht, aber es gibt tatsächlich Leute bei uns im Forum, die haben schon Ultraschall-Sensoren angebracht und haben da auch Experimente mitgemacht.
Damit könnte man dann, was könnte man machen? Man könnte nach unten gucken und schauen, ob da irgendwie Boden ist. Sollte das hilft das oder ist das nicht nötig? Ja gut, wenn man da relativ weit streut, dann sieht man ja vielleicht auch so einen Busch.
Also unser großer Vorteil ist ja, dass wir relativ schnell sehr große Höhe gewinnen können. Und wenn ich den Mikrokopter auf 25 Meter Höhe habe, dann ist so schnell kein Baum oder kein Busch mehr in der Nähe.
Aber ein Vogel vielleicht oder?
Ja, die fliegen schon alle drumrum.
Ja, stimmt, die haben bestimmt kein großes Interesse mit so einem sierenden Monster. Habt ihr dann auch schon mal so Vögeljagd gemacht? Wie verhalten sich denn so Vogelgruppen, wenn man sich da...
Weiß ich nicht, also die interessieren sich da nicht groß für. Nachbarskatze, die kann man da ganz gut mit ärgern mit so einem Ding.
Ah ja, okay, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Das heißt, dieser Luftdrucksensor reicht euch jetzt eigentlich auch schon so mit der Höhe? Ich meine, würde das jetzt, keine Ahnung, wenn man jetzt so ein bisschen, das wie beim Pferdesport macht und da so ein Parcours aufstellt, wo er dann zwischen irgendwas auf so einer bestimmten Höhe durchfliegen muss, also gibt es irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, eine absolute Höhe damit auch wirklich zu messen und sich dabei halbwegs sicher zu sein? Oder ist das nur so, ich bin so hoch genug und ich bin jetzt wahrscheinlich gleich auf der Erde?
Also der, wir verwenden den Höhen-Sensor hauptsächlich dafür, dass wir ihn auf eine konstante Höhe halten. Das heißt, ich fliege nirgendwo hin, kann ja den Mikrokopter auch per GPS halt auf dieser Stelle halten und dann hält er sich halt auch automatisch auf der richtigen Höhe. Das ist eigentlich der Hauptgrund, weil Höhe darf man ja auch nicht vergessen, ist ja immer relativ vom Untergrund. Das heißt, wenn ich in einer bergigen Landschaft fliegen würde und wollte immer zwei Meter über den Boden fliegen, dann muss ich natürlich was ganz anderes machen, als wenn ich mich an den atmosphärischen Luftdruck hänge, der an jeder Stelle gleich ist auf dem Höhen-Niveau.
So, das heißt, das ist jetzt sozusagen eigentlich das Trippel, was jetzt wirklich auch ausreicht. Also man braucht den Gyro und man braucht die Beschleunigungs-Sensoren insbesondere, damit sie sich gegenseitig korrigieren. Und mit dem Luftdrucksensor weiß man dann auch noch...
Ja, der Höhen-Sensor ist im Prinzip schon aus der Luftdrucksensor, der ist eigentlich schon optional. Das heißt, das brauche ich nicht unbedingt zum Fliegen. Das heißt also, die anderen Sensoren reichen völlig aus, damit kann ich meinen Spaß haben, damit kann ich die Gegend heizen und fliegen. Nur wenn man halt den Höhen-Sensor hat, dann kann man halt wirklich auf eine Stelle fliegen und ich liege einen Schalter um und der fliegt mir nicht nach oben weg. Gerade am Anfang, wenn man noch ein bisschen unsicher ist, vielleicht mit der Steuerung, ist das eine große Hilfe.
Sonst hätte man ja die Fernbedienung, könnte man sagen, okay, jetzt geht er zu weit nach oben.
Ganz so macht man es ja normalerweise. Also das würde völlig reichen.
Das heißt, da geht man schon sozusagen den ersten Schritt in so eine autonome Steuerung? Und jetzt hast du es schon. Ja, was fehlt denn noch? Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, hat das Ding auch noch einen Kompass?
Das ist auch optional. Also zum Fliegen reicht es wirklich. Die Jarskope und den Beschleunigungssensor, der Dreiecksige, das reicht.
Okay, dann gehen wir nochmal so in die optionale Sensorik mit rein. Meine GPS hast du schon erwähnt. Weiß nicht, was man da als erstes betrachten sollte. Also GPS, das ist dieses Navi-Board, richtig, was ihr noch dazu wollt. Was gehört da dazu?
Also das Navi-Board, das ist eine Platine, die sieht so ähnlich aus wie der Lagerrechner, also die Flight Control. Die ist 5 x 5 cm groß. Das ist eine kleine Leiterkarte. Die kann man über die Flight Control montieren. Und darauf kann man halt den Kompass montieren und nochmal das GPS-Modul. Das Navi-Board an sich besteht nur aus einem schnellen Prozessor, einem ARM 9, der die Navigationsdaten verrechnet, also die GPS-Daten und die Kompass-Daten.
Man braucht beides.
Ja.
Weil GPS einem ja eigentlich nur so einen Punkt im 3D-Raum gibt, aber man weiß nicht, wohin man guckt.
Ja, genau so ist das. Viele glauben, man würde aus dem GPS auch eine Nordrichtung bekommen. Das ist aber nicht richtig, weil das GPS kann einem zwar angeben, in welche Richtung ich mich bewege, in welche Himmelsrichtung, aber nicht in welche Richtung meine Nase jetzt gerade guckt.
Das heißt, wenn man steht, dann kriegt man einfach keine Differenzsignale, sondern kriegt man immer nur, du bist an derselben Stelle und hat keine Bewegung.
Richtig. Und wenn ich mich jetzt auf der Position halten wollte und ich werde jetzt zum Beispiel vom Wind zwei Meter weg geblasen, dann kann ich anhand der GPS-Koordinaten halt sehen, wie weit ich weg bin vom Zielpunkt und dann kommt der Kompass ins Spiel, der weiß dann, in welche Richtung muss ich dann fliegen tatsächlich, um wieder auf die Originalposition zurückzukommen.
Ah, weil sonst würde er ja so ein bisschen Pi mal Daumen, also ich flieg jetzt mal irgendwo hin, ach nee, das war falsch, lieber dann doch mal in die Richtung. Ah, verstehe, wie genau ist dieser Kompass?
Der ist sehr genau, also das ist eine Auflösung von 1 Grad und der Genauigkeit von, was weiß ich, 3 Grad oder so was. Also das ist völlig ausreichend.
Und ich glaube, ich habe hier mal so ein Video gesehen, was du glaube ich auch in deinem Garten aufgenommen hast, als irgendwie Strom war. Das war dieses Naviboard, was da zum Einsatz kam.
Also das ist eins der ersten Videos gewesen. Da habe ich das Ding noch manuell geflogen, aber wir haben auch schon Videos gemacht, wo wir mit Sturm und Naviboard geflogen sind. Das funktioniert auch.
Und dann kommt so die, also wenn ich mich richtig noch erinnere, da kam irgendwie so, da war so richtig so fett Sturm. Also sah zumindest so aus, weiß ich es nicht. Also ich sah es ja nur hinter dem Rechner und nicht auf der Wiese. Aber da war schon ordentlich Wind. Das heißt, der Wind hat eigentlich im Prinzip das Ding die ganze Zeit weggedrückt. Und der hat die ganze Zeit gemerkt, ich bin nicht an dem Ort, wo ich eigentlich sein möchte. Und wie genau wird das GPS-Signal, dann wird dich gemessen? Meine GPS ist ja nicht hier so mega hochauflösend eigentlich.
Doch, die Auflösung ist relativ hoch. Und die Auflösung ist ein Zentimeter bei GPS, nur die Genauigkeit halt nicht. Das ist ein Unterschied. Also wir lösen das schon mit der höchsten GPS-Genauigkeit auf, das ist ein Zentimeter. Und der Mikrokopter versucht halt auch, sich an diesen einen Zentimeter-Genauigkeit zu halten. Und je nachdem, wie gut man empfängt, funktioniert das halt mal besser und mal schlechter.
Das heißt, ihr merkt schon, wenn das Teil zehn Zentimeter weggeschoben wird, ihr könnt euch bloß nicht sicher sein, ob das jetzt wirklich auch die Koordinate ist, von der behauptet wird, dass es ist.
Ja, so ist es im Prinzip.
Könnte sozusagen auch die Koordinate seine 100 Meter weiter ist, aber die eigentliche Differenz merkt er. Könnte man nicht auch den Beschleunigungs-Sensor für solche Berechnungen heranziehen?
Das machen wir auch.
Das fließt mit ein?
Ja, das fließt dann mit ein.
Aber das Navibord hat jetzt nicht nochmal einen eigenen, sondern nehmt schon den, der normalerweise da ist?
Ja, genau. Das Navibord lässt sich die Daten zuschicken vom Beschleunigungs-Sensor. Das wird dann wieder verrechnet mit den Drehratensensoren, also mit der aktuellen Lage. Und dann wird halt dadurch nochmal die seitliche Bewegung noch mal gedämpft.
Das heißt, ihr nehmt eigentlich alles, was so an Sensorik irgendwie zu greifen ist, und lasst das in eine große Berechnung hineinfallen. Und das trifft dann sozusagen die Aussage darüber.
Genau. Und effektiv kann man mit GPS ungefähr, also bei relativ wenig Wind, vielleicht so auf ein Meter Genauigkeit die Position halten.
Das ist jetzt auch schon alles fertig entwickelt. Das funktioniert schon. Das ist aber eine relativ neue Geschichte. Das kam, glaube ich, erst dieses Jahr dazu, oder?
Nee, das kam letztes Jahr dazu.
Im Herbst.
Ach so, ja, wir haben ja schon 2008.
Ja, das kam im Herbst dazu.
Ja, genau.
Okay, ja, in 2008. Ich habe den Jahreswechsel, glaube ich, noch nicht vollständig abgeschlossen.
Also gemein ist halt, das ist zum Beispiel Bögerwind. Das macht natürlich nicht so schön, weil so gleichförmiger Wind, der kann gut ausgeglichen werden. Aber wenn natürlich jetzt Böen kommen, so wie hier, wir teilweise auch draußen haben, dann ist natürlich klar, da gibt es erstmal seitwärtige Beschleunigung, die müssen immer wieder abgefangen werden. Dann sind die auch noch verschieden stark. Das macht natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger. Aber grundsätzlich wegfliegen würde er nicht.
Was für Sensoren könnt ihr euch denn noch, also haben wir noch irgendwelche vergessen?
Ja, es wird noch ein bisschen Spannung und Strom gemessen, aber das ist nicht so spannend.
Das ist nicht so spannend für Batteriezustand, sozusagen.
Ja, genau, so ist es.
Ach so, das Ding ist ja auch in der Lage, festzustellen, wenn es keinen Saft mehr hat, oder?
Ja, das ist auch ganz wichtig.
Was macht der dann?
Der meldet das über so einen Piper. Und der macht dann einen ziemlichen Lärm. Und das merkt man dann schon früh genug.
Ich bin hungrig.
Das macht er grundsätzlich, wenn er irgendwelche Probleme hat. Das heißt, auch wenn er Empfangsstörungen hätte.
Kann man das hören?
Das kann man definitiv hören.
So hört sich das dann an.
Und dann ist irgendwie angesagt, mal besser mal landen. Wie lange hält der Strom dann noch, wenn er irgendwie so rumnervt?
Also man kann dann vielleicht noch eine halbe oder eine Minute noch fliegen, je nachdem, wo man halt seine Schwelle eingestellt hat. Man kann das halt einstellen, wann die Warnung kommen soll.
Und wenn er schon so out of reach ist, man mit seiner Fernbedienung gar nicht mehr rankommt, weil man ihn irgendwie in den Wald geschickt hat und dann die Verbindungen abgebrochen, das meint er aber auch.
Das erkennt er auch. Also er erkennt auch einen Empfangsausfall und geht dann selbstständig in den Sinkflug.
Oder auch wenn der Strom sozusagen aus ist. Und das heißt dann sagt er irgendwie, okay, alles klar, mich kontrolliert keiner mehr, beziehungsweise ich habe jetzt eh gleich keinen Strom und ich habe keine Hoffnung mehr, dass ich korrekt nach unten geleitet werde. Dann kündigt er sozusagen die Beziehung und geht einfach nach unten.
Ja, so ist es im Prinzip.
Ah, und landet.
Samft. Ja, natürlich.
Ja, oder weniger sanft.
Völlig sanft.
Ja, aber es ist schon gut, dass er halt nicht die Motoren gleich abschaltet und so runterkippt, weil er dann sofort mit Erdbeschleunigung runterdonnert. Es wird halt ein gewisser Grundschub dann noch eingestellt und dann kommt er halt tatsächlich mit den Füßen nach unten auf.
Wie stabil ist denn das Gerät so?
Mechanisch stabil, oder was meinst du?
Ja, ja, so ich meine gerade so die Rotoren, wenn die irgendwo reindonnern, zerbrechen die schnell.
Rotoren ist ein Verschleißteil, würde ich mal ganz klar sagen, die Propeller. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, die mechanische Konstruktion ist sehr simpel und sehr stabil. Das heißt, es verbiegt vielleicht mal ein Alu-Ausleger, wenn man es mal richtig drauf anlegt. Den kann man wieder gerade biegen, das ist auch gar kein Problem. Sonst ist mechanisch ja alles sehr einfach. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt, wenn ich mal wieder den Helikopter-Vergleich nehme, wo wirklich eine Verstellung der Rotoren da ist, wenn ich da irgendwo anecke, dann habe ich erst mal eine Woche Reparaturarbeit, weil wirklich feinste Mechanik da gemacht werden muss. Und hier muss ich vielleicht mal einen Motor tauschen, wenn es wirklich arg ist oder ein Lager. Aber in der Regel, meistens passiert gar nichts, oder es bricht halt ein Propeller, den tausche ich aus. Das ist ein kleines Teil, gar kein Problem, ich kann so weiterfliegen.
Was kosten so Propeller?
Das Propeller-Papier liegt irgendwo knapp vier Euro.
Das ist normal Plastikpropeller?
Das ist ein Plastikpropeller.
Genau.
Gibt es das nicht dann auch immer gleich so in so teuren Varianten mit Fiberglas?
Ja, es ist halt, ja, es ist sicherlich, man kann sowas, es gibt einige, die machen das CFK selbst zum Beispiel auch. Das Problem bei den Propellern ist ja, dass wir links- und rechtsläufige brauchen. Weil die Motoren drehen ja links und rechts rum, das hatten wir ja gerade. Und das ist halt kein Standardteil, linksläufiger Propeller. Den kann man also so einfach nicht kaufen. Das heißt, es gibt nur sehr wenige und das schränkt halt die Auswahl sehr ein.
Ah, verstehe. Normalerweise drehen die sich immer alle in eine Richtung.
Und unsere Propeller, die sind relativ leicht. Also ein so ein Propeller wiegt, was weiß ich, sieben Gramm oder was. Und wenn man jetzt in so einen voll drehenden Propeller mal mit den Fingern reinkommt, dann bleiben auf jeden Fall die Finger dran. Also man kriegt zur Not vielleicht mal eine Schnittverletzung, eine kleine. Aber das ist jetzt nicht so, dass es jetzt irgendwie nehmensgefährlich ist, wenn man jetzt in den Propeller reinkommt.
Auch wenn die mit so 15 bis 10.000?
Also der Finger bleibt dann dran.
Sollte man jetzt nicht unbedingt ins Auge bekommen, aber...
Ja, genau. Also wenn ich jetzt einen wesentlich stabileren Propeller hätte und einen wesentlich schwereren, dann hätte ich schon viel mehr Respekt vor dem Gerät und würde auch nicht mehr so auf mich zufliegen oder ihn aus der Luft fangen. Aber mit diesen...
Da könnte ja dann die Fledermaus-Funktion irgendwie helfen, dass man irgendwie sieht, oh, Kollision.
Ja, wenn das alles funktioniert, dann wohl.
Was für Wunsch sind, Zurek, habt ihr denn noch so auf eurer Liste? Was könnte man denn noch alles so mit einbauen? Also, was gibt es noch für Sensoren? Infrarot?
Ja, also optische Entfernungsmessungen nach unten zum Beispiel wäre interessant. Vielleicht optische Sensoren.
Also sowas wie Laser oder was?
Ja, es gibt zum Beispiel mit Laser gibt es Abstandsmessungen. Der projiziert quasi den Punkt nach unten auf den Boden. Und dann wird über verschiedene Verfahren gemessen, wie weit der Lichtfleck entfernt ist. Und so könnte man natürlich ganz hervorragend die Höhe über den echten Boden halten. Also wenn ich jetzt den Berg hochfliegen würde, dann könnte ich immer drei Meter Abstand vom Boden haben, wenn ich wollte. Also das wäre zum Beispiel eine ganz interessante Sache. Oder ich könnte mir zum Beispiel vorstellen, dass ich eine Landeplattform habe mit einer Markierung. Keine Ahnung, ein Schwarzes Kreuz oder sowas. Und lasse das Ding dann halt autonom genau auf diesen Punkt landen.
Da würde man dann wahrscheinlich wieder mit Kamera arbeiten.
Ja, das wäre so eine Kamera, richtig. Da müsste man halt MPEG-Algorithmen oder sowas nehmen, die erzeugen dann schon genau die Bewegung dieser Muster. Man kann auch Mustererkennung dann programmieren und so weiter.
Und damit könnte man dann auch so ein bisschen so, ich meine, ihr kennt ja sicherlich auch diese Rohmbar, diese Staubsauger-Roboter, die dann irgendwie zu Hause durch die Wohnung fahren und alles wegputzen. Die haben ja auch dieses lustige Feature, dass sie dann ihre Ladestationen automatisch finden können. Ich bin da auch schon mal in die Richtung experimentiert.
Ja, das wäre auch eine nette Idee. Man könnte zum Beispiel sagen, man hat so einen kleinen Infrarotsender an der Ladestation, hat so ein paar Kontakte unter den Füßen oder wie auch immer. Und der würde genau diesen Punkt halt anfliegen, würde sich da selber laden und dann...
Könnte man sozusagen rund um die Uhr sein Grundstück überwachen.
Ja, wie auch immer.
Mit fliegenden Hubschraubern. Da freuen sich die Nachbarn. Aber ansonsten seid ihr irgendwie ganz zufrieden und da gibt es jetzt nichts mehr dran zu entwickeln. Das ist alles toll. Das Projekt ist total.
Nein, nein, keine Sorge. Keine Sorge. Also wir haben genau genommen, wir haben erst richtig angefangen. Wir haben ja vor zwei Jahren erst damit angefangen. Und wir entwickeln da ständig weiter und verbessern das und so weiter.
Man kann es ja schon mal vorweggreifen, was wir schon mal erwähnt haben, können wir nachher darüber reden. Das ist jetzt nicht nur so euer privates Projekt, sondern ihr stellt ja die Hardware auch zur Verfügung. Also ihr verkauft das als fertige Bausätze. Also fertig nicht im Sinne von fertig fliegt sofort, aber muss man sich sozusagen zusammenstecken und dann fliegt er. Und stellt entsprechend auch die Software dafür bereit. Also wenn man sozusagen selber so ein Gerät haben möchte, kann man das bei euch quasi in Rohform bestellen und zusammenstecken und dann hat man den gleichen Spaß. Aber vielleicht noch mal so kurz zu dem, wie das alles so funktioniert und was man damit machen kann. Also dieses Modell, was jetzt hier gerade auf dem Tisch steht, das hat da so eine kleine Videokamera, so sieht es aus, dran gebammelt.
Was macht die? Ja, was man auch machen kann, was auch ganz nett ist, man kann zum Beispiel diese Videokamera anschließen und auch eine Videobrille. Dann könnte man zum Beispiel auch mit Videobrille fliegen, das heißt so First-Person-View mäßig, könnte man dann auch mal ein bisschen durch die Gegend fliegen. Was schön ist an dieser Videokamera ist, wir haben zusätzlich noch eine Neigungskompensation, das heißt, wenn wir den Mikrokopter nach vorne fliegen, also neigen, dann neigt sich die Kamera entgegengesetzt, dass ich immer in etwa denselben Bildschirmausschnitt habe. Das ist ganz praktisch, was sonst würde ich entweder den Fußboden sehen, oder ich würde den Himmel sehen, je nachdem wo ich fliege, und das wäre sehr kontraproduktiv.
Und wie läuft diese Kommunikation, ist es einfach so ein analogisches Videosignal?
Ja, also was wir jetzt hier drauf haben, das ist eine ganz einfache 2,4 Gigahertz Video-Übertragungsstrecke, und da gibt es Standard-Komponenten überall zu kaufen.
Also jetzt nicht mit irgendwie verschlüsselter Kommunikation und Pippa-Pose, sondern wird halt einfach...
Gibt es mit Sicherheit auch, aber wir haben halt das genommen, was man so einfach kriegen kann. Das soll ja eben auch kostenmäßig im Rahmen bleiben.
Was kostet so was?
100 Euro würde ich mal so schätzen.
Ah, also geht so.
Ja, je nachdem, es gibt Kameras von bis, das ist ja immer so die Sache, und die Videobrillen genauso. Je nachdem, welche Auflösung ich habe oder ich kann auch 500, 600 Euro für so eine Videobrille ausgeben.
Und dann hat man jetzt sozusagen aber wirklich das fliegende Auge, so im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Man setzt sich die Kamera aus, wie weit reicht das? Also wie weit kann das Ding wegfliegen und man kriegt noch ein halbwegs brauchbares Bild davon?
Also mit den normalen Sachen, die man so einfach hier in Deutschland benutzen darf, kommt man so ein paar hundert Meter weit. Das ist auch nicht ganz unproblematisch, weil es ist ja 2,4 Gigahertz, das ist 10 mW Sendeleistung und das ist auch der Bereich, wo Bluetooth arbeitet, WLAN arbeitet und wenn ich jetzt tatsächlich irgendwo mir aus dem Ausland vielleicht einen entsprechend starken Sender besorgen würde, dann würde ich im Umkreis das WLAN lahmlegen oder so was, das wäre also nicht besonders gut. Davon abgesehen, dass es nicht erlaubt ist.
Ja, oder sich WLAN eigentlich schon selber weitgehend lahmlegt durch das andere WLAN, was sonst immer noch so rumfliegt.
Das ist noch ganz nebenher.
Aber das heißt, wenn man so mal euer Experiment da auf der Autobahn so ein bisschen weiter denkt, dann könnte man sozusagen auf der Autobahn fahren, irgendwie mit einer Videobrille auf und der Copter fliegt über einem und man hat dann endlich mal so den Blick, den Lastwagenfahrer auch haben. Was habt ihr damit so experimentiert? Gibt es da irgendwie? Ich meine, da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass da ein paar nette Anekdoten schon zusammengekommen sind.
Das ist auf jeden Fall unheimlich viel Spaß. Also man hat das Gefühl, dass man halt in dem Mikrokopter selbst drin sitzt, man fliegt ihn auf Höhe, man lockt vielleicht mit GPS ein und guckt sich erstmal um. Man dreht sich auf der Stelle und sieht die Welt halt aus der Vogelperspektive. Man kann sich da selber auf dem Fußboden stehen sehen. Man kann um sich herumfliegen und...
Ich habe da so auch so zwei, drei artenberaubende Videos gesehen. Es gibt ja so eine Video, so eine Videoplattform im Netz. Wie heißt sie noch gleich? Wo diese ganzen Modellbau-Sachen sind?
Rcmovie.
Rcmovie, genau. Da findet sich viel, oder? Oder gibt es noch eine andere Quelle?
Genau, wir benutzen hauptsächlich Rcmovie und Pimeo, natürlich auch YouTube.
Okay, aber da findet sich jetzt insbesondere viel, alles was aus diesem Modellbau-Charakter ist. Da kann man mal suchen, was nicht...
Mikrokopter ist als Stichwort schon ziemlich gut.
Mikrokopter ist schon mal ganz gut noch ein Stichwort, womit man diese Kameravideos findet.
Ja, also wir haben bei uns auf der Homepage auch eine Auswahl der Videos, weil wenn man sonst Mikrokopter eingibt, dann wird man erschlagen von Videos. Aber wenn man bei uns jetzt auf die Homepage geht, da haben wir extra eine Video-Seite, da ist das Best-of, da sind wie 100 Videos oder so was.
mikrokopter.de.
Genau.
Ja, das kann ich also jedem nur empfehlen, da mal reinzuschauen. Ich erinnere mich da nur an so einen Fluss entlang, so mit Pappeln und so. Also einfach mal total schicke Optik. So Hollywood, irgendwie selbst gemacht. Also sicherlich auch ganz interessant für Leute, die jetzt, ich philosophiere mal, keine Ahnung, wenn ich einen Film drehen würde, ja und ich träume von diesen Special Effects, wie man sie halt bei teuren Produktionen einsetzt. Also da muss man sich nicht einen Hubschrauber für mieten. Da kann man eben auch mit so was arbeiten.
Genau, man kann auch mit ganz einfachen kurzen Luftaufnahmen so ein einfaches Video sehr stark aufwerten. Ich hatte letztens einen, der macht gerne Videos von Hochzeiten zum Beispiel. Und dann hat er nur ganz zu Anfang des Filmes halt eine so eine Szene, wo er halt auf diesen Altar drauf zufliegt oder auf dieses Paar. Er ist vielleicht nicht während der Hochzeit, sondern vorhergestellt.
In der Kirche oder was?
Nee, also das war irgendwie draußen oder so. In der Kirche ging das natürlich im Prinzip auch.
Aber es war so eine Open-Air-Hochzeit.
Ja, genau. Und dann fängt er seinen Film halt mit 15 Sekunden Flugvideo an und dann hat man natürlich schon gleich eine ganz andere Einstellung.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Das kommt bestimmt ganz cool. Aber dieses Videoteil, das wir jetzt eben besprochen haben, was also Live-Video gemacht hat, das macht natürlich keine besonders gute Qualität. Da müsste man schon dann nochmal eine ordentliche Kamera quasi zusätzlich anbringen.
Ja, also wir machen ganz gerne so eine kleine Digitärkamera darunter. Da eignet sich zum Beispiel so eine X-Sus ganz gut. Und die hat auch den Vorteil, dass sie auch diese Neigungskompensation mit einem kleinen Servo macht. Das heißt also auch wenn ich fliege, wenn ich Videos mache zum Beispiel, habe ich auch einen vernünftigen Bildausschnitt. Das habe ich in der hohen Auflösung, weil das wird direkt auf die SD-Karte der Kamera gespeichert.
Und wie kriegt ihr die Kamera dazu, im richtigen Moment auch einzuschalten oder setzt ihr die vorher einfach auf Rekord und dann fliegt ihr los?
Genau, also wenn ich jetzt ein Video mache, dann mache ich halt vorher Rekord und die fliege ich los. Hinterher kann ich mir das ja zusammenschneiden, wie ich es haben möchte.
Gibt es da auch eine Fernbedienungsoption?
Man könnte auch was fern auslösen, das geht grundsätzlich auch. Weil wir können über unsere Flight-Kontrolle haben wir auch ein paar Schaltausgänge. Darüber kann man Lichter schalten, wenn man möchte. Ganz lustig, aber ich kann zum Beispiel auch als Auslöseserror benutzen und dann im Prinzip den Knopf drücken der Kamera.
Ich sage, verschiedene Kameras kann man auch über USB direkt steuern, oder?
Gibt es auch.
Habt ihr USB auf eurem Gerät?
Die direkt steuern kannst du es nicht, aber du kannst zum Beispiel über dieses USB im Prinzip eine Auslösung machen. Das heißt, ich gebe dir einfach nur einen Impuls drauf und dann kann ich auslösen. Das geht. Und Videos kann man sehr gut machen. Einfach anschalten, losfliegen. Wenn ich Fotos machen will, also wir machen es meistens so, dass wir so eine Automatik einschalten, alle drei Sekunden Bild. Dann fliegt man halt mal und hinterher guckt man sich die Bilder an. Das ist sehr schwer, direkt den Punkt zu treffen, wo ich jetzt auslösen möchte.
Das ist schwierig.
Dann kann ich besser sagen, ich fliege jetzt einfach drum herum, mache da mal 100 Bilder, auf der SD-Karte ist genug Platz, und gucke mir hinterher die besten Bilder an. Das gibt eigentlich ein ganz gutes Ergebnis.
Ja, da trifft man dann auf jeden Fall irgendwas letztes. Aber ihr könnt aber auch schon direkt Kommunikation machen. Also es gibt so ein Bluetooth-Modul, oder?
Ja, wir können auch digitale Daten übertragen. Und dann das PC-Programm, also unser Kopter-Tool, vom Boden aus betreiben. Und können uns Messdaten angucken oder was auch immer.
Aber da geht es sozusagen um die Sensoren, wie man das in der Formel 1 auch macht, dass alle Wagen sozusagen die Telemetrie übertragen.
Das ist der richtige Begriff.
Das macht ihr über Bluetooth. Und das ist da auch standardmäßig dabei?
Ja, das sind Standard-Komponenten, die kann man dann anschließen.
Ist das jetzt alles so modular aufgebaut, dass man alles noch mal dazustecken kann?
Ja, das ist im Prinzip ein Bluetooth-Modul, das ich an die Serie-Schnittstelle von der Karte anschließen kann. Muss ich zwei Stück von haben oder einen Bluetooth-Dongel. Und dann habe ich die Option, dass ich drahlos was machen kann.
Bevor wir zu der Software kommen, sagen wir mal auf die Elektronik, was befindet sich auf dem Gerät, was diese Berechnungen durchführt? Woüber haben wir jetzt gesprochen?
Der Hauptmikrokopter besteht im Prinzip neben den Motoren. Dann braucht er halt diese vier Motorregler, diese vier Brushless-Regler. Und dann im Prinzip nur noch die Flight Control, also die Platine mit den Sensoren und dem Hauptrechner. Die ist 5 x 5 cm groß. Und dann hast du noch einen Fernbedienungsempfänger. Der ist auch nicht allzu groß, der ist dreimal 2 cm groß. Und den Akku, das war's dann schon.
Und was ist da jetzt drauf auf dieser Flight Control?
Da habe ich erstmal den Hauptprozessor drauf. Das ist ein 8-Bit-AdMill-Prozessor. Daran angeschlossen ist dann ein Baustein, der beinhaltet den dreiaxigen Beschleunigungssensor. Und dann die drei Drehratensensoren sind getrennt. Also getrennte Bausteine sind halt auch verlötet auf der Leiterkarte. Dann habe ich noch einen Spannungsregler, den Luftdrucksensor, ein paar Operationsverstärker, um die Signale zu verstärken. Und serielle Schnittstelle, das war es dann im Prinzip schon.
Und die serielle Schnittstelle ist sozusagen der Weg, über den man dann auch das Ding neu programmiert, mit neuer Firmware ausstattet und so?
Genau, mit der seriellen Schnittstelle kann ich ihn parametrieren. Also ich kann das Flugverhalten ändern, indem ich ein paar Parameter ändere. Oder ich kann Software neu einspielen. Oder an die serielle Schnittstelle wird auch das Naviboard angeschlossen, was halt oben drüber gesetzt wird.
Was für eine serielle Schnittstelle ist das? Reden wir jetzt von V24 oder?
So was in der Art. Asynchronel.
So was in der Art?
Nein, V24 ist plus minus 12 Volt. Und wir arbeiten mit 0 und 5 Volt als Pegel.
Ist das jetzt was eigenes oder ist das ein Standard?
Nein, das ist Standard.
Wie heißt der Standard?
Mit TTLP-Genhalt.
Ja, asynchroner D-Anvertragung. Mit 750 Kilo Baut und 8-Bit.
Das heißt, so ein normaler Atmel-Prozessor, der nicht gerade zu den leistungsfähigsten Chips gehört, die man heute kaufen kann, reicht eigentlich aus, um diese 500-Hertz-Überwachung aller Sensoren und die entsprechende Steuerung des Gerätes zu machen.
Genau, also der hat 64 Kilobyte Flash und arbeitet mit 20 Megahertz. Ist also 20 Mal schneller als ein C64. Und da wissen wir, glaube ich, alle, was der schon damals schon für eine Leistung hatte.
Das stimmt. Und dieses Navi-Board, das ist ja dann ungleich komplexer, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Da ist ja dann kein Atmel-Prozessor mehr drauf verbaut.
Ja, da ist ein ARM 9-Prozessor drauf. Und der hat 512 Kilobyte-Flash, also deutlich mehr als ein 96K RAM. Dann ist zusätzlich auf dem Navi-Board, das hatten wir noch nicht erwähnt, auch ein Mikro-SD-Karten-Sockel drauf. Das heißt, da ist auch eine SD-Karte drauf. Das heißt, der ARM macht auch ein Fallsystem. Ich kann zum Beispiel meine GPS-Daten auf diese SD-Karte loggen, im KLM-Format. Kann ich dann in Google Earth reinladen und ich kann hinterher mal schauen, wo bin ich denn geflogen. Schön in 3D mit Höhe und allem drum und dran. Und ein großer Vorteil ist halt, gerade so was Navigation angeht, muss man auch mit floating points rechnen, Sinus und Cosinus und das ist halt für den Kleinen dann irgendwann doch vorbei und dann muss man halt ein bisschen Leistungsstärke und Kontrolle haben. Der kann mit 96 MHz betrieben werden.
Aber ihr betreibt ihn nicht so schnell?
Im Augenblick betreiben wir ihn etwas langsamer. Reicht im Augenblick und wir können ihn dann hoch skalieren. Das ist eine PLL drauf. Oder dann mehr Strom fressen. Genau, so sieht es nämlich aus.
Ist der Strombedarf dann überhaupt signifikant?
Im Vergleich zu den Motoren ist nichts signifikant, würde ich mal sagen. Das sind die Stromfresser, die die Flugzeit bestimmen, die ungefähr zwischen 15 und 20 Minuten liegt, je nachdem, was ich drunter habe. Also wie viel Pilot ich benutze.
Kann man damit mit mehr Akkus irgendwas reißen? Oder wird das Ding dann insgesamt zu schwer?
Das ist das Problem. Ich kann ja nicht sagen, ich mache jetzt 10 Akkus drunter. Da fiege ich ja gar nicht mehr, weil es zu schwer ist. Das ist ein Trugschluss. Doppelt so viel Akku kapazitiv drunter und ich habe doppelte Flugzeit. Das haut einfach nicht hin. Man kann sicherlich, wenn man einen leichten Rahmen nimmt, das heißt Gewichtsparen überall, kann man Flugzeiten von 30-35 Minuten, würde ich mal vielleicht im Extremfall als realistisch betrachten. Aber wenn man es ein bisschen stabil haben will, dann landet man irgendwo bei 25 Minuten vielleicht.
Also wie alle wartet ihr auch sozusagen auf die nächste Generation von Akkutechnik, um da irgendwie was zu verbessern? Zeitnet sich da schon irgendwas ab, was du im Modellbau sich da vielleicht durchsetzt? Lithium-Polymer oder so?
Ja, Lithium-Polymer haben wir ja jetzt drauf.
Ach so, habt ihr schon.
Also man hört öfter mal Nachrichten über leistungsstärkere Akkus, aber ich habe noch keinen gesehen, der da tatsächlich mal mitgeflogen ist. Aber ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass innerhalb der nächsten 10 Jahre sich da noch gewaltig was tut. Also alleine eine Verdreifachung der Kapazität wäre ja schon eine Verdreifachung der Flugzeit. Dann könnte man eine Stunde in der Luft bleiben. Das wäre schon gigantisch.
Bei gleichem Gewicht?
Genau.
Und ist es bei den Motoren noch irgendwie davon auszugehen, dass das sich signifikant verändert? Oder ist das schon ausgereizt?
Gut, das kann natürlich auch sein, dass die mal etwas besser werden, aber die sind vom Wirkungsgrad schon so hoch, dass man jetzt sagt, wenn man jetzt wirklich die besten Motoren hätte, die man sich vorstellen kann, dass man halt jetzt nicht die Flugzeit verdoppelt, sondern halt nur ein paar Prozent gewinnt.
Und kann man so am Gehäuse selber noch was optimieren? Ich meine, Alu ist recht leicht, aber vielleicht was, was ich so mit...
Carbon zum Beispiel, CFK, könnte man was machen, das wäre leichter.
Bringt das viel?
Es bringt auf jeden Fall was. Aber das Problem ist halt auch, wie die Crash-Resistenz dann ist, wenn man tatsächlich mal abstürzt. So ist es halt wirklich wesentlich einfacher. Alu hat sich in vielen Experimenten bei uns als das Ideale erwiesen einfach.
Weil das verbiegt dann vielleicht, aber Carbon bleibt halt entweder heile oder ist gleich kaputt.
Und ist auch preislich interessanter. Also diese Alustäbe sind verhältnismäßig günstig. Spezialanfertigung, Carbon, vielleicht gefräste Sachen, das kostet auch alles sehr viel.
Man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass der Akku ist ja nicht fest eingebaut, das heißt, der ist ja nur drunter geschnallt mit Klettband. Und wenn ich einfach noch mal länger fliegen will, dann schnall ich einen zweiten Akku drunter. Also nehme ich den alten leeren Akku wieder ab und wechsel den dann halt.
Aber zwei Akkus jetzt anzuschließen, würde schon nichts bringen, weil das Gewicht dadurch so signifikant verändert wird?
Ja, genau. Es gibt da so einen gewissen Schnittpunkt, so ein gewisses Optimum, das liegt vielleicht bei 30 oder 40 Minuten. Aber eine Verdopplung der Akkukapazität würde dadurch nicht zwangsläufig eine Verdopplung der Flugzeit mehr bewirken.
Ich würde es auch nicht schneller machen, weil er mehr Power ziehen kann oder so. Ich weiß nicht, was man bei 100 km noch steuern will. Das ist ja wirklich echt atemberaubend, finde ich wirklich unglaublich. Kommen wir vielleicht mal so zur Software. Ihr habt ja auch noch ein recht umfangreiches Tool entwickelt, was unter Windows läuft. Ich habe mir das hier vorhin mal kurz zeigen lassen, was im Prinzip so die Telemetrie- Überwachungsstation ist. Das ist so die Hauptanwendung von dem Gerät.
Im Prinzip kann man sich fast sämtliche Werte, die irgendwie in dem Controller auflaufen, anschauen. Das sind zum Beispiel die Winkel, die Beschleunigungswerte von den Gyros. Also im Prinzip alles, was irgendwie für Debugging interessant sein könnte, kann man sich anschauen, einmal als Zahlenwert, aber auch grafisch darstellen. Dann hat man im Prinzip so eine Art Oszidoskopie, will ich mal fast sagen. Man kann dann praktisch, wenn man den Mikrokopter mal nickt, zum Beispiel nach vorne dreht, dann kann man sofort die Ausschläge sehen. Da kann man auch sehr schön sehen, ob die Elektronik das macht, was sie eigentlich soll. Vielleicht ist ja eine Beschädigung da irgendwie. Vielleicht hatte ich einen Absturz und irgendwas funktioniert nicht mehr richtig, dann kann ich sofort sehen, mein Gyro funktioniert nicht mehr oder sowas. Dann kann ich über dieses Mikrokopter-Tool sämtliche Parametrierungen ändern. Das heißt also, ich kann das Flugverhalten in Grenzen einstellen. Wir haben sogenannte Settings, nennen wir das. Die kann man auch mit der Fernbedienung auswählen, bevor man startet. Wir haben fünf Settings, die man abspeichern kann. Und da gibt es zum Beispiel ein Sport-Setting. Bei uns heißt es halt Sport-Setting. Das ist ein sehr giftiges, möchte ich mal sagen. Das heißt, der Kopter sitzt sehr dicht an den Sticks. Das heißt, wenn ich den nach vorne bewege, dann reagiert er sehr spontan. Das ist also richtig dicht. Dann gibt es so ein Beginner-Setting. Das ist sehr träge, weil gerade am Anfang hat man das Gefühl für die Fernbedienung nicht richtig. Das heißt, ich schlage viel zu stark aus. Und das wird dann alles gedämpfter. Das heißt, alles ein bisschen moderater, langsamer. Was auch sehr schön ist, wenn man eine Kamera drunter hat. Wenn man aufnimmt, dass man nicht so zackige Bewegungen hat. Das kann man halt in weiten Teilen selber einstellen. Wir haben zum Beispiel auch vorhin schon erwähnt, diese Notgas-Geschichte. Das bedeutet bei Empfangsausfall, dass er halt in diesen Schwebezustand übergeht und diese Schwelle kann ich einstellen. Das ist halt abhängig von meinem Gewicht. Da habe ich einen leichten Kopter. Dann muss ich halt einen kleineren Wert einstellen, weil sonst würde vielleicht sogar steigen. Und habe ich halt für so etwas besonders Schweres, dann könnte ich diese Schwelle halt noch verändern. Genau so kann ich zum Beispiel einstellen, diese Unterspannungsgrenze, bei der ich anfangen soll, mich zu signalisieren, dass das Akku leer ist. Und so kann ich halt viele einzelne Parameter einstellen und die auch auf verschiedenen Settings abspeichern, die ich einfach beim Start, bei Fernbedienung, ohne dass ich jetzt ein PC-Programm brauche, abrufen kann.
Und spielt man darüber auch dann die Software ein, die neue Firmware?
Ja, also mit diesem Tool kann man im Prinzip alles machen, d.h. diese Parametrierung, Settings-Geschichte, Debugging und auch das neue Einspielen der Firmware.
Dazu muss man dann den Copter aber direkt dann anschließen?
Ja, also das würde auch über Bluetooth funktionieren. Sollte man den Flug nicht unbedingt machen, ist nicht irgendwie gerade so, aber theoretisch machbar.
D.h. aber, dass man dann auch Bluetooth im Rechner braucht?
Wenn man das mit Bluetooth macht. Normalerweise, wir haben so ein kleines Adapter-Platinchen gemacht, per USB, das steckt man einfach an seinem USB-Port, ein Kabel dran und dann kann man updaten. Das benutzt man eigentlich.
Dann geht man sozusagen direkt an diese Serial-Geschichte?
Ganz genau, das ist das, was man eigentlich auf jeden Fall braucht, weil man muss auch diese Parametrierung halt machen, d.h. auf seine Fernbedienung, auf seine Funke einstimmen, dass das alles passt, von den Kanälen. Bluetooth ist halt optional.
Und das ist dann sehr schick, d.h. man kann irgendwie fliegen und während das Ding fliegt, überträgt er per Bluetooth die Sachen. Ist das jetzt nur für Telemetrie die Bluetooth-Geschichte oder ist das auch um, was weiß ich, Kamera-Fernauslösung, hat man schon mal so als Idee, habt ihr jetzt so nicht drin? Gibt es da noch andere Anwendungen?
Eine schöne Anwendung ist auch z.B. nach Waypoints zu fliegen. Das heißt, ich habe auf dem PC, so ähnlich wie bei Google Earth, eine Karte und mache dann Doppelklick drauf und dann fliegt da automatisch den Punkt an.
Aber so mit Google Maps oder was?
Ja, das ist ein Programm bzw. das ist gerade in der Entwicklung. Der holt sich im Prinzip die Daten von Google Maps, also die Bilder, und benutzt halt dann die Karten.
Das heißt, man kann da einfach so, wie man es gewohnt ist, von Google Maps zoomt man sich irgendwo so einen Ort raus und sagt, da möchte ich jetzt irgendwie hinfliegen.
Man muss natürlich zwangsläufig immer in Reichweite des Senders bleiben.
Merkt man das eigentlich bei Bluetooth, wenn man so out of range ist, so ein bisschen digital, dass es dann irgendwie entweder geht oder es geht nichts mehr?
Ja, dann ist weg. Also dann ist der Empfang weg.
Und hat das Gerät dann so ein, ich muss wieder da hinfliegen, wo meine Homebase ist?
Ja, das ist möglich.
Das heißt, man könnte ihn schon so einstellen, dass er dann, also wenn er das Navi-Board hat, das ist ja noch mal optional, dass er dann halt einfach so, muss er ja eh haben für diese Funktion, ist ja klar.
Und er fliegt grundsätzlich nicht ohne die normale Fernsteuerung. Das heißt also, man darf nicht die Fernsteuerung ausmachen. Das ist kein Ersatz. Das ist mehr eine Option, die man nebenbei hat. Das heißt, wenn man den Sender ausschalten würde, dann würde er sofort im Fangstoffsfahre melden, egal was das PC-Programm sagt, er würde auf jeden Fall landen.
Das ist eine Sicherheitsverbindung im Prinzip. Also der Pilot, der am Sender ist, hat immer vollen Zugriff auf das Fluggerät.
Da gibt es auch rechtliche und versicherungstechnische Vorschriften. Also dieses Gerät läuft im Prinzip wie ein normales Modell. Flugzeug oder Hubschrauber kann man das ganz normal über die Modellhaftpflichtversicherung versichern. Kostet irgendwo 40, 50 Euro im Jahr. Normale Haftpflicht deckt das in der Regel nicht ab. Und dann kann man auch im Garten fliegen zum Beispiel. Und man hat Versicherungsschutz. Und davon muss man halt Standardkomponenten haben. Man braucht diesen Empfänger, man braucht diesen Sender.
Also wenn man so ein Nachbarshund mit dem Mikrokopter mal so einen neuen Haarschnitt verpasst.
Genau, wenn es da versicherungsrechtliche Probleme gibt, dann ist das halt abgedeckt dann.
Okay. Auch wenn jetzt die, wie wir schon gesagt haben, die Gefahr an sich nicht sehr groß ist, passieren kann natürlich immer was, was weiß ich.
Ja, der Pilot kann ja auch einen Fehler machen. Ich kann mich ja mal versteuern und ich fliege in das Haus.
Und das ist ja immerhin ein Kilo Gewicht, was da in der Luft hängt. Und wenn das Ding da auch so 100 Meter runter donnert, dann ist es immerhin ein Kilo. Genau.
Und möchte nicht so ohne weiteres gerne mal ein Kilo auf den Kopf kriegen. Verständlich. Das machen alle Versicherungen oder?
Wie gesagt, es gibt diese speziellen Modellflugversicherungen dafür. Die muss man auch dafür extra abschließen.
Okay, aber die gibt es dann auch bei mehr als nur einer Versicherung. Aber vielleicht einmal so im Hinblick auf diese autonome Geschichte. Es gab ja im letzten Jahr eine Veranstaltung bei Berlin auf dem selben Gelände in Finnowfurt, wo auch das letzte Camp stattgefunden hat. Die Micro-Drone, wart ihr da auch?
Motordrohnen.
Motordrohnen, Entschuldigung.
Nee, da waren wir nicht.
Da wart ihr nicht.
Nein.
Aber davon habt ihr natürlich gehört.
Wir haben davon gehört. Ja, es war terminlich fast unglücklich gelegt, weil es zum selben Zeitpunkt eine Veranstaltung in Köln gab. Ein großes Quadrocopter-Treffen, was alljährlich da stattfindet. Und da waren Termine fast unglücklich gelegt in Berlin.
Ah ja, verstehe. Aber das ist ja sozusagen der Versuch, gerade diesen autonomen Fliegeaspekt nochmal so ein bisschen Anschluss zu geben. Aber es ist, glaube ich, eine neue Veranstaltung geplant jetzt in diesem Jahr. Da seid ihr dann dabei.
Ja, wir werden uns das auf jeden Fall angucken.
Aber ihr habt jetzt selber keinen besonderen... Also autonom fliegen ist jetzt nicht euer Ding. Euch geht es im Wesentlichen um die Entwicklung der Plattform.
Genau, wir fliegen natürlich auch autonom, aber uns interessiert hauptsächlich die Technik. Wie funktioniert das? Warum funktioniert das? Wie kann man es entwickeln und so weiter?
Die Plattform ist ja jetzt von relativ vielen Leuten aufgegriffen worden. Habe ich so den Eindruck, es gibt rund um die Webseite. mikrokopter.de ist im Wesentlichen ein Wiki, oder? Forum ist auch noch mit dabei, was nicht? Vielleicht könnt ihr mal kurz sagen, was sich dahinter so verbirgt.
Ja, also mikrokopter.de selber ist ein Wiki, hat auch schon ziemlich viele Seiten, wohl im Prinzip jeder, wie man es halt kennt vom Wiki. Man kann etwas eintragen und verbessern, wächst ständig. Und da findet man die ganzen Grundlagen, die man so braucht. Und zu sich haben wir halt noch einen Forum, mittlerweile recht stark besucht. Also wir laufen jetzt auf die 100.000 Beiträge zu. Knapp 3.000 User haben wir. Und da kann man im Prinzip alles fragen. Und innerhalb kürzester Zeit hat man da Antworten drauf.
3.000 User, heißt das auch wirklich 3.000 Leute ein eigenes Gerät?
Nee, das wäre schön. Nein, so ist es wohl nicht. Nein, also wir haben auch eine Map bei uns drauf. Das heißt, man kann sie im Prinzip eintragen, wenn man das möchte, wo man halt einen Standort hat. Das ist ganz praktisch, wenn man zum Beispiel Gleichgesinnte in seiner Umgebung sucht. Und da sind auch mit, glaube ich, 800 Leuten eingetragen.
Und so viele Bausätze habt ihr auch schon unters Volk gebracht?
Ja, wir verkaufen ja diese Bausätze in verschiedenen Ausbaustufen. Das heißt, wir sind ja damals angefangen und haben diesen Brushless-Regler für uns entwickelt. Und diese Flight-Control. Und dann war ja eigentlich nur für uns gedacht das Hobby. Und dann kam halt die Nachfrage, das ist ja klasse, möchte ich auch. Und dann hat man halt das Problem, man braucht Platinen zum Beispiel. Und dann sind wir halt angefangen und haben gesagt, okay, dann lassen wir halt mal ein paar produzieren. Und dann haben wir die halt angeboten über unseren Webshop, den wir dann aufgesetzt hatten. Und dann kam das nächste Problem, ich kann nicht löten. Zumindest kann ich das nicht löten, weil es ja doch relativ klein ist. Dann sind wir halt beigegangen und haben Stück für Stück auch zusätzlich vorbestückte Platinen angeboten.
Das ist ja auch sehr kompakt, das ist so SMD-Technik.
Das ist SMD-Technik, genau.
Also in der Anfangszeit mussten die Leute die selber bestücken. Also die hatten nur die nackte Leiterkarte. Und hatten im Prinzip einen Warenkorb bei einem Elektronikhändler. Haben sich da die Widerstände zuschicken lassen. Und die Dinger haben da selber draufgelötet.
Das ist natürlich nicht unbedingt jetzt jedermanns.
Nö, das ist für die Elektroniker halt. Und wie gesagt, es kamen dann auch immer mehr Modellflieger, die das auch interessant fanden, die aber nicht unbedingt so die Elektroniker sind. Und für die haben wir halt die Möglichkeit geschaffen, dass wir die Platinen vorbestücken. Das ist ja auch ein erheblicher Zeitaufwand. Und man kann sich jetzt immer noch aussuchen bei uns, ob man wirklich unbestückte Platinen kauft und sich die Teile selber besorgt und drauflötet, oder ob man halt auf vorbestückte Platinen, die dann halt getestet und schon programmiert sind, zurückgreift.
Und das heißt, man kann jetzt davon ausgehen, es sind so ungefähr 800 bis 1000 von diesen Geräten mittlerweile als Bausatz verkauft worden und fliegen im Idealfall auch alle noch. Das heißt, das ist ja schon eine ganz amtliche Community, die da zusammengekommen ist. Was wird denn da so, ich nehme mal an, dass die jetzt nicht nur im Kreis fliegen, sondern auch eigene Entwicklungen da vorantreiben. Was gibt es da schon andere Subprojekte, die für euch so interessant sind?
Ja, die Leute modifizieren natürlich die Software, die halt ändern vielleicht das Flugverhalten, die Höhenregler oder was auch immer. Oder auch ganz interessante Projekte. Zum Beispiel, einer hat ein Programm geschrieben, um den Mikrokopter per Handy zu steuern. Der nennt das Projekt Dabweis. Und dann hat man im Prinzip das Kopter-Tool, was man normalerweise auf dem PC hat, hat man auf dem Handy.
Also auch mit der ganzen Telemetrie und so.
Ja, richtig. Man kann also sämtliche Parameter über das Handy ändern, über Bluetooth. Wir haben das sogar so weit getrieben, dass wir den Mikrokopter per Handy steuern konnten.
Auf was für Handys läuft das? Ist das so eine Java-Software, die auf vielen Sachen läuft?
Richtig.
Und dann sind wir halt so spaßeshalber mit diesem kleinen Handy-Stick, also mit diesem kleinen Steuerkreuz auf dem Handy, mit dem Mikrokopter geflogen. Also da gibt es ganz verrückte Sachen.
Also es ersetzt vollständig die Vermehrung sozusagen?
Nein, nicht wirklich. Man kann bei weitem nicht so richtig damit fliegen. Das Primärziel dieser Anwendung war eigentlich diese Parametrierungsgeschichte. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwo im Feld bin und ich möchte halt irgendwie den Flugverhalten doch ändern, was ich vorher vielleicht nicht eingestellt habe mit meinem PC, dann muss ich meinen Laptop nicht mitnehmen, sondern ich kann einfach mal ein Handy, das habe ich sowieso dabei, das nehme ich und tippsele das dann schnell um und ich kann weiterfliegen. Dafür ist es eigentlich hauptsächlich diese.
Also bei stürmischem, windigem Wetter, wo es so leicht nieselt und so, ist natürlich ein Handy eine ganz andere Art und Weise praktisch als ein Laptop.
Genau. Also Steuerung ist jetzt zum Beispiel auf dem Kongress jetzt in Berlin. Da hatte einer was vorgestellt, der hat das mit einer Wii-Fernbedienung geflogen tatsächlich. Aha. Also mit dieser, man kennt es ja von dieser Spielekonsolen. Damit konnte man schon sehr feinfühlig steuern, weil ja auch der Beschleunigungssensor und sowas ist eine so eine Wii-Fermedienung auch drin. Also da gibt es auch so Sachen, wo da irgendwelche Joystick-Anwendungen, da gibt es auch so Space-Joysticks für irgendwelche Flugsimulatoren versuchen da auch einige dann auf die Mikrokopter-Steuerung zu portieren. Also da gibt es halt diverse Ansätze.
Und unabhängig von anderen Steuerungsmethoden, was wir schon angesprochen hatten, gibt es Leute, die Ultraschall-Sensoren einbinden? Gibt es da noch so andere Sachen, wo...
Dann gibt es Leute, die bauen Leiterkarten, um Daten ins Videobild einzublenden. Das ist im Prinzip eine Platine, die sieht ähnlich aus wie unsere Flight-Control, auch etwa gleicher Abmaße. Die können sich direkt Daten in das Videobild einmischen.
Das heißt, gerade wenn man jetzt so mit Videobrille fliegt, dann hat man dann so diesen Terminator-Effekt, dass dann so irgendwie die ganzen Parameter eingezeigt werden, wie schnell man fliegt oder wie hoch man ist.
Richtig. Oder zum Beispiel ganz wichtig, dass man sich anzeigen lässt, wie weit bin ich von meinem Startpunkt weg und in welche Richtung liegt mein Startpunkt. Weil man verpflichtet sich sehr schnell, wenn man nach Videobrille fliegt, besonders wenn man die Umgebung vielleicht nicht besonders gut kennt. Das heißt, man steht plötzlich vor einem Baum oder zwischen zwei Bäumen oder über einem Baum oder wie auch immer und man weiß überhaupt nicht mehr, wo muss ich jetzt überhaupt hin.
Oder im Baum.
Und sowas kann man sich dann halt ins Bild einblenden und dann...
Im Pfeil sozusagen.
Und dann gezielt zurückfliegen.
Du bist hinten links. Ah ja, verstehe. Pfiffig.
Ja, Akkuspannung auch ganz interessant. Dann zum Beispiel noch. Dann sieht man halt, wie viel Kapazität hat man noch.
Und solche Software-Sachen, fließt denn das dann auch in eure Firmware wieder mit ein? Also gibt es da auch so einen Austausch in der Software oder sind das alles unabhängige Entwicklungen?
Also das war jetzt, was ihr jetzt angesprochen habt, dieses EPOSD-Projekt. Das ist halt eine eigenständige Geschichte. Die haben auch einen eigenen Wiki, wo man auch die Leiterkarten kaufen kann mit einer eigenen Software. So praktisch als Add-on für den Mikrokopter.
Aber ansonsten gute Ideen und so was, das fließt natürlich ein.
Dann sollte man vielleicht nochmal kurz was zu eurer Lizenz sagen. Das ist ja jetzt kein Open-Source-Projekt, wie man das jetzt vielleicht eigentlich häufig findet, sondern ihr habt da eine Einschränkung. Also ihr gebt schon die Software schon im Source-Code raus, also die Firmware ist vollständig da. Man kann die auch nehmen, man kann die auch modifizieren. Welche Einschränkung gibt es?
Also im Wesentlichen haben wir halt die Einschränkung, dass es nur für den privaten Gebrauch ist. Das heißt also non-commercial, wenn man so sagen möchte. Das heißt, wenn jemand jetzt den Mikrokopter benutzt, um irgendwie Geld damit zu verdienen, dann muss er sich halt mit unserer Verbindung setzen, dann müssen wir das klären, wie wir das dann machen können. Aber für die private Anwendung kann man im Prinzip machen, was man möchte.
Aber das wird auch getan. Also es gibt auch Leute, die jetzt den Mikrokopter auch für kommerzielle Anwendungen übereintesten.
Ja, das wird auch getan. Und die Community wacht auch ganz gut darüber. Es kommt öfter mal ein Beitrag im Forum, wenn man dann sieht, das sieht aber verdammt nach Mikrokopter aus, dann macht jemand Luftbildaufnahmen und das sieht auch wie ein Mikrokopter. Ist das denn in Ordnung und sowas? Also doch, die Leute melden sich aber auch.
Das ist für euch sozusagen auch Teil des Deals, dass ihr eure Entwicklung sozusagen mit der Community teilt, aber ihr wollt halt diese Einschränkung machen.
Nun, eine andere Einschränkung ist halt auch, dass die Software auf unserer Hardware betrieben werden soll. Das heißt, es kann jetzt nicht ein was weiß ich, jetzt ein chinesischer Spielzeughersteller kommen und einfach Platinen auf den Markt bringen und unsere Software da einspielen. Das ist halt eine Sache, die wollen wir verhindern und sagen halt von daher, ihr könnt eure Software ändern, aber lasst sie bitte auf unserer Hardware.
Und gibt es dann aber dann trotzdem die Bereitschaft dann auch sozusagen Softwareänderungen, die jetzt gemacht wurden, dann auch wieder zurückfließen zu lassen? Ich weiß nicht, wie eure Erfahrungen sind mit der Community. Es gibt jetzt natürlich die, ja, ihr wisst schon, die freie Software, freie Hardware-Bewegung, wo dann immer alle Änderungen natürlich auch geteilt werden müssen. Und dann wurde es natürlich dann auch sehr viel schneller wieder mit einfließend an solches Projekt. Was habt ihr da so für Erfahrungen gemacht?
Ja, es ist ja so, wenn jetzt jemand die Software grundsätzlich ändert und wieder hochlädt, wir haben ja einen SVN, und es soll halt in diesen Haupt-Software-Strang mit einfließen, dann muss es natürlich grundsätzlich gründlich getestet werden. Und von daher kann natürlich nicht jede kleine Änderung, die jemand gemacht hat, um halt irgendwie einen Portbett zu schalten oder sowas gleich vollständig mit einfließen. Also das müssen dann schon Sachen sein, die gut funktionieren und die auch durchschaubar sind, wie sie funktionieren. Und dann wird so eine Idee schon ganz gerne mal übernommen.
Aber eure Software ist halt auf so einem Subversion-Server und ihr macht da schon ein öffentliches Development und es gibt auch andere Leute außer euch, die da schreiben dürfen. Aber ihr seid sozusagen diejenigen, die in den letzten Endes die Entscheidung überführen, was man in den Trunk genommen hat.
Genau, wir machen halt den Trunk, dann können halt ihre Branches machen. Und die Hauptsache ist, wenn wir ein offizielles Release machen und da gehen auch der normale Modellflieger, das benutzen ja im Prinzip mehr oder weniger alle. Und das ist nicht ausreichend getestet und die Dinger fallen alle vom Himmel, warum auch immer. Das wäre nicht gut. Das heißt, da ist so ein bisschen Verantwortung auf unserer Seite, die wir da haben.
Ich habe gehört, es gibt dann auch noch einige Unis, die die Mikrokopter-Plattform verwenden. Könnte dir da was zu sagen?
Ja, also Unis setzen die ganz gerne ein für ihre Regelungstechnik-Labor zum Beispiel. Oder die machen halt Sensorauswertungen damit. Die bauen halt etwas zusätzlich ein, dass sie halt irgendwas überwachen. Was weiß ich, Luftverschmutzung oder keine Ahnung. Und da gibt es halt auch einige Projekte, die interessieren sich für Steuerungstechniken. Die bauen sich da Kameras drunter und steuern den Mikrokopter halt über Bewegung des Kamerabildes und so weiter. Also da gibt es diverse verschiedene Projekte.
Gibt es da eine Übersicht? Habt ihr das auch auf eurer Webseite, diese Projekte?
Nee, die gibt es nicht. Die Übersicht haben wir nicht.
Leider eigentlich.
Stimmt, das ist ein guter Ansatz. Könnte man mal aufnehmen. Man sieht öfter mal Publikationen im Netz, dass irgendwelche Unis dann ihre selbstentwickelten Quadrokopter vorstellen. Meistens ist es dann Mikrokopter als Basis. Das geht dann meistens aus der Berichterstattung auch nicht so vor. Es gibt so diverse Unis, die den Mikrokopter praktisch selber entwickeln möchten. Was dann in der Regel aber unser Mikrokopter war. Die haben dann eben eine Erweiterung gemacht, wie gesagt, optischer Fluss oder Bilderkennung.
Wobei das ja wahrscheinlich dann in der Regel ein Problem der Wahrnehmung durch die Medien ist. Ich denke, solche Details werden dann auch nicht unbedingt immer ohne Weiteres umgesetzt.
Ja, das ist leider so. Viele Sachen werden dann in irgendwelche Artikel geschrieben und das ist dann halt nicht ganz richtig. Aber in der Regel, wenn man die Leute dann anschreibt, dann wird das auch korrigiert.
Was gibt es denn jetzt außerhalb der Mikro... Ich meine, es gibt ja auch noch andere, das sollte man auf jeden Fall auch nochmal erwähnen, es gibt ja auch noch andere Quadrokopter-Projekte, die Ähnliches tun wie ihr. Es ist ja nicht so, dass es jetzt nur Mikrokopter gibt, sondern es gibt ja auch noch ein paar andere Projekte. Könnt ihr da vielleicht mal einen Überblick geben, soweit ihr da Bescheid wisst, was es da so gibt und wo die sich unterscheiden?
Ja, also es gibt zum Beispiel, also ganz zu Anfang muss man vielleicht mal das XUFO-Forum erwähnen. Das XUFO-Forum ist eines der ersten Foren gewesen, die sich überhaupt mit dem Thema beschäftigt haben. Das XUFO an sich ist das Spielzeug von Silver Lead gewesen, was ich vorhin erwähnt hatte.
Von?
Silver Lead, so nennt sich die Firma. Und das ist so ein Schaumstoffrahmen gewesen, mit halt auch vier Gleichstrommotoren, also vier Motoren und einem mechanischen Kreisel. Und das hat damals auch schon einen großen Andrang gefunden. Und dadurch ist halt dieses XUFO-Forum entstanden. Dann gab es auch einige Entwickler, die haben sich da eine Elektronik darauf entwickelt. Die stecken auch irgendwie mit in der Entwicklung von diesem Silver Lead-Gerät mit drin. Die haben damals schon die ersten elektronischen Kreisel eingesetzt. Die nennen das X3D oder nennen das X3D, das gibt es noch. Und die haben halt auch ein eigenes Projekt davon entwickelt. Und dann etwa zeitgleich mit unserem Projekt ist das UHVP-Projekt entstanden. Die haben auch eine eigene Webseite www.uhvp.de oder so.
Findet ihr auf jeden Fall in den Links dieser Sendung.
Genau.
Die werde ich dann noch bereitstellen. Richtig.
Und die sind im Prinzip einen ähnlichen Weg gegangen wie wir. Haben halt auch eigene Elektronik entwickelt. Und es ist halt so nebenbei entstanden. Also nebenher.
Das ist aber dann ein richtiges Open Source-Projekt, wo alles offen ist. Bist du nicht?
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Muss noch mal schauen.
Ich weiß es auch nicht, deswegen frage ich blöd.
Ja, also die sagen von ja. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es so ist.
Also Quellen habe ich noch nicht gesehen, also jetzt direkt, aber wird wohl so sein.
Okay, alles klar. Ja, ähm, vielleicht nochmal so zu diesem Sache. Also es ist ja, also ihr habt diese Software, die jetzt bei euch unter Windows läuft, also das Mikrokopter-Tool. Das selber ist jetzt nicht publiziert. Das ist also nicht Teil der Software. Also die Software, die ihr sozusagen rausgibt und die ihr öffentlich entwickelt, das ist die eigentliche Firmware, die also auf dem Gerät läuft. Aber die Protokolle, die jetzt mit dem Gerät gesprochen werden, die sind ja, ich meine, zwangsläufig sind die ja sozusagen offen. Die habt ihr auch nochmal separat dokumentiert.
Die sind auch dokumentiert, ja.
Okay. Und es gibt auch alternative Programme, die jetzt auch, wir hatten ja schon das Beispiel mit dem Handy, das ist ja im Prinzip schon mal so eine Variante, aber es gibt auch noch andere Tools, oder?
Ja, es gibt auch noch eine, die nennt sich hier QMK Ground Station, die läuft unter Linux, oder auch unter Mac, auf Qt-Basis zum Beispiel. Da kann man im Prinzip auch alles mitmachen, was man mit dem Mikrokopter-Tool machen kann. Firmware-Update geht auch. Unter Linux ist es halt etwas schwierig. Man kann es in der Virtual Machine, kann man es laufen lassen, das Mikrokopter-Tool, aber es ist halt nicht so schön, gerade für so Linux-Anwender, die möchten halt ungern Windows-Tools einsetzen, ist so eine Sache. Also das gibt es zum Beispiel, das funktioniert auch.
Gut, haben wir denn auch irgendwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen zu erwähnen? Ein ganz guter Ritt hier irgendwie durch die Technik und durch die Community. Wie ist denn so euer, was mich noch mal interessieren will, wie ist denn so euer Verhältnis zu dieser ganzen Community, die da immer abwächst? Wenn da irgendwie 3000 Leute in dem Forum so sich rumtoben, habt ihr da eine relativ enge Nähe? Du hast von diesem Treffen geredet. Was, das findet einmal im Jahr statt, sagst du?
Ja, ein-, zweimal im Jahr in Köln, da sind halt viele auch aus dem XUFO-Bereich, zum Beispiel auch, das ist nicht speziell Mikrokopter, es geht halt um Quadrocopter allgemein.
Generell, okay.
Generell, das sind dann so um die 100 Leute, waren glaube ich letztes Mal da, ich weiß nicht genau.
Hat das einen Namen, das Treffen, oder ist das einfach das Treffen?
Quadrocop, gibt es glaube ich auch noch, müssen wir nachher in der Links mal schauen. Und da treffen sich halt viele, und dadurch kennt man auch sehr viele aus dem Forum, gerade in diesem Bereich jetzt, aber wir sind ja auch international nicht nur auf Deutschland beschränkt, sondern Mikrokopter gibt es in ganz Europa, Amerika, Australien und...
Mikrokopter oder Quadrocopter?
Mikrokopter, Quadrocopter vielleicht auch, aber ich weiß halt mehr von Mikrokoptern.
Okay, also euer Ding macht es jetzt schon über die Grenzen von Deutschland hinaus?
Ja, das ist weltweit im Einsatz. Und ja, Community, das muss ich sagen, da muss ja noch ein besonderer Dank an die Community richten im Prinzip, weil was die an Support leisten, das könnten wir gar nicht so nebenbei, weil es gibt halt, wir machen es ja mehr oder weniger, sag ich mal, nebenbei. Wir sind beide selbstständig, aber dieses Projekt läuft im Prinzip nur nebenbei, will ich mal sagen, und hat auch einen erheblichen Supportaufwand. Und gerade so Wiki-Forum und auch der Chat dämpft schon viel weg. Es kommen so noch genug Mails durch, die wir auch noch beantworten müssen. Dadurch schaffen wir es manchmal auch gar nicht, das Forum auch zu lesen. Wir liegen bei, ich glaube, 90 Beiträgen pro Tag. Das ist schwierig, wenn die neu hinzukommen. Und man kann einfach nicht alles lesen. Das geht einfach nicht. So Schlüsselsachen, da werden wir darauf aufmerksam gemacht, wenn was ist. Aber es ist halt sehr schwierig.
Gibt es da jetzt eine deutsche und eine englische Sektion, wenn da jetzt schon so viel internationaler...
Überwiegend deutsch, weil es ist halt deutsch entstanden. Wir haben aber im Forum so eine Untergruppe, so eine international Area, wo halt auch englisch gepostet werden kann oder auch was anderes. Und grundsätzlich kann man auch grundsätzlich Englisch posten, aber das wird sofort englisch geantwortet. Unser Wiki ist auch zweisprachig. Das heißt, ein Großteil ist in Deutsch die Anleitung, aber so Schlüsselkomponenten sind ebenfalls in Englisch, teilweise auch in Italienisch. Und in Spanisch kommt jetzt auch noch was dazu. Das wird dann halt von den Usern halt dann wieder bereitgestellt.
Und wo geht jetzt so die Reise hin? Also was sind so eure nächsten Ziele bei der Weiterentwicklung? Was habt ihr so für Probleme noch, die zu lösen gilt?
Also im Moment entwickeln wir eine Flight-Control mit besseren Sensoren, mit weniger Temperaturdrift.
Macht das wirklich so viel aus? Das ist wirklich so ein Problem. Weil die Komponenten taugen nicht so?
Ja, das ist halt auch eine Preisfrage, ob so ein Sensor halt 25 Euro kostet oder halt 60 Euro. Das macht dann doch schon einen großen Unterschied. Und da gibt es halt qualitativ auch große Unterschiede. Und das ist ein Thema, wo wir im Moment dran sind.
Das heißt, es gibt unter Umständen nämlich so eine Flight-Control Pro-Version, die dann mehr kostet, aber besser funktioniert? Ja. Wie macht sich das dann so im Flug bemerkbar? Also ich meine, ich habe immer so den Eindruck, die Dinger fliegen einfach stabil. Kann ja auch daran liegen, dass derjenige, der es dann von Hand steuert, das irgendwie ganz gut im Griff hat, aber es ist ja nicht so, dass die jetzt rumeiern und irgendwie so Albatross-Airlines-mäßig durch die Gegend fliegen und landen. Was fehlt euch da?
Also wenn du wirklich optimale Sensoren hast, dann kannst du bei Windstille das Ding in die Luft stellen und es bleibt da tatsächlich stehen. Wenn du jetzt eine leichte Temperaturdrift hast, dann reicht sich der Mikrokopter halt um, sagen wir mal, ein Grad oder zwei Grad. Und das reicht schon, um ihn von der Stelle zu treiben.
Das heißt, er schwebt dann wirklich weg.
Genau.
Und wenn das Naviboot nicht hat, dann kriegt er es halt auch nicht korrigiert.
Und ihr wollt eigentlich dahin, dass das Ding einfach an dem Punkt festgenagelt ist.
Es macht es ja auch wesentlich einfacher für das GPS zum Beispiel. Wenn das Gerät von sich aus halt stabil ist auf der Stelle, also möglichst stabil, das macht es halt alles wesentlich gutmütiger. Und gerade so Anforderungen jetzt, wenn man jetzt kommerziell widerspricht, es gibt halt auch so Luftbildfotografen und die möchten nach vornherein natürlich auch das bestmögliche haben, wenn es geht. Das heißt, wenn man dann halt etwas mehr dafür ausgeben muss, hat er aber einen stabileren, wir sind in der Position hoh, das heißt auf der Stelle bleiben, was gerade bei Luftbildaufnahmen interessant ist, dass man über ein Objekt schweben kann und man bleibt halt da. Das ist halt ein wichtiger Aspekt.
Das ist so im Wesentlichen jetzt die nächste Entwicklung?
Das wird als nächstes kommen. Das ist die nächste Entwicklung, die kommt. Vorstellbar wäre vielleicht auch noch was an den Brushless-Regler mal was zu machen. Die sind ja auch, sag ich mal, aus der ersten Stunde noch. Da könnte man auch mal gucken, ob man da was findet. Und mal gucken, vielleicht kommt noch eine ganz tolle Idee aus der Community im nächsten Woche. Und wir machen dann das. Das ist immer so ein bisschen spannend.
Also ihr habt jetzt nicht irgendwie so 20 Sachen, die man mal alle mal machen müsste. Und ihr wisst gar nicht, was ihr als nächstes macht. Sondern ihr konzentriert euch da jetzt erst mal konkret auf diese...
Ja, doch. Also die Liste ist schon riesig, was man alles machen könnte. Ich habe zum Beispiel im Dezember einen Octocopter aufgebaut.
Ah, ja richtig. Den habe ich sogar gesehen.
Ein Monster. Das ist dasselbe Funktionsprinzip. Hat aber anstatt von vier Propellern acht Propeller.
Und anstatt zum Zweierkreuz sozusagen vier Aluschienen, die dann so an vier Punkten miteinander verbunden sind, plus noch mal die Mitte. Und da hängen dann acht riesen Flügel dran. Sind die auch noch mal größer als die anderen?
Nein, die sind genauso groß.
Ach so, okay, ich habe jetzt die falsche Perspektive. Was bringt das? Ist das jetzt noch mal so aus Bass an der Freud?
Es hat schon einen technischen Hintergrund. Der riesen Vorteil ist, erst mal kann er mehr Gewicht tragen. Das heißt, ich könnte eine größere Kamera drunter machen, wenn ich wollte. Und ein weiterer Aspekt ist...
Wie viel Gewicht haben wir da überhaupt schon drüber gesprochen? Ich glaube, wir haben nur gesagt, was das Ding wiegt, aber nicht, was es so wiegen darf.
Also die Geräte wiegen ja so etwa zwischen 700 und 1000 Gramm. Und die können noch mal so 300, 400 Gramm mitnehmen.
Und beim Octocopter? Der wiegt ja an sich natürlich schon mal viel mehr.
Ja, das ist schon richtig. Ich kann fast das Doppelte an Gewicht mitnehmen.
Das heißt, der wiegt... Was wiegt der? Wiegt der an sich? Ich würde mal sagen, das Doppelte.
Ich glaube, der wiegt 1200 Gramm plus Akku. Also irgendwie 1500 Gramm wiegt der. Und kann natürlich dementsprechend mehr Gewicht mitnehmen, wenn er wollte. Und ein weiterer Respekt ist, es dürfte im Flug sogar ein Propeller abfliegen oder ein Motor ausfallen. Der würde sich trotzdem stabil in der Luft halten.
Nur einer?
Es dürfen im Prinzip vier Motoren ausfallen. Das müssen die richtigen sein.
Das heißt, das Ding ist so ein bisschen fehlertolerant. Aber ich meine, das passiert ja relativ selten. Das ist jetzt nicht wirklich ein Problem.
Wenn ich jetzt an einem Baum vorbei fliege und ich komme jetzt mit dem Propeller an einen Ast, dann kommt er schon zum Stehen.
Das heißt, das ist vielleicht so ein bisschen der Prototyp für Anwendungen in kritischen Umgebungen. Das weiß ich. Aber zum Beispiel auch, wenn ich eine Schlucht wo man ihn dann nicht so ohne Weiteres wieder retten kann, wenn er wirklich mal...
Vielleicht. Aber auch wenn ich zum Beispiel eine teure Hardi-Kamera vielleicht mehrere tausend Euro da drunter hängen habe, dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich doch ein besseres Gefühl, wenn ich wüsste, es dürfte mal was kaputt gehen und es fällt nicht sofort runter. In gewisser Redundanz ist es auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht. Wo man sagen muss, auch bei dem kleineren Quadrocopter könnte man grundsätzlich mehr Gewicht drunter hängen, aber es schließt sich halt sehr stark in der Flugzeit zu Buche. Das heißt, erst mal wird das Flugverhalten, es wird alles sehr viel träger und schwerer. Und ich weiß nicht, ob es viel bringt, dass man dann mit einem Kilo noch fünf Minuten fliegen kann. Das bringt natürlich nicht wirklich was.
Ist der Octocopter denn schon eine abgeschlossene Entwicklung oder ist das noch so ein Experimentalstudium? Könnte man da die wesentlichen Parametersteuerungen einfach so übernehmen oder gab es dann neue Herausforderungen?
Also im Dezember habe ich die Software soweit erweitert, habe die Software auch schon publiziert. Und es gibt auch schon etliche Leute, die haben sich das Ding nachgebaut und fliegen damit. Also man kann sicherlich noch einiges verbessern, aber es fliegt schon ganz erstaunlich gut.
Und was ist noch so im Regal? Ich bin ganz begierig. Also ich wüsste wirklich gerne wohin ihr da, wo ihr sozusagen da noch Erweiterungsmöglichkeiten seht, wie man das zum Einsatz bringen kann. Ich meine jetzt so rein in der Anwendung, das ist ja jetzt eigentlich weniger euer Ding, weil ihr euch ja eigentlich auch die Entwicklungen habt. Da kann man sich ja was weiß ich einfallen lassen. Also mit GPS und Kameras und so.
Ja genau, gerade mit GPS und so weiter, da gibt es etliche Anwendungen. Ich habe zum Beispiel mal das Schwamm fliegen probiert. Das heißt, ich habe zwei Mikrokopter in die Luft gebracht mit zwei Sendern. Und die beiden kommunizieren über Bluetooth untereinander und schicken sich gegenseitig die Position zu.
Also die machen dann sozusagen autonome Peer-to-Peer-Kommunikation.
Richtig.
Und der eine sagt, ich bin hier, und der andere sagt, ich komme. Richtig. Und dann fliegt er immer hinterher.
Genau, der ist immer hinterher geflogen. Oder ich kann mir einen Peilsender in die Hosentasche stecken und der Mikrokopter fliegt mir autonom hinterher.
Also sozusagen ein GPS-Empfänger. Und der wird dann per Bluetooth an den Links und dann... So ist es. Ist das so, wie ihr das auf der Autobahn auch gemacht habt?
Nein, das war nicht die Autobahn. Das war schon ein Feldweg. Aber so eine Autobahn wäre natürlich nicht möglich gewesen.
Also hier gibt es sehr abgelegene Ecken, wo man so was machen kann.
Wir sind ja hier auf Schlesland.
Ja, na nein, den habe ich damals schon per Hand gesteuert. Aber rein theoretisch wäre das möglich, das stimmt schon.
Okay, dann hätte man immer so seinen Buddy. Dann wäre noch eine Ladestation oben aufs Auto.
Also das sind so Sachen, das sind so Spielereien, die wir einfach mal ausprobieren und die auch ganz hervorragend funktionieren.
Ja, super. Super Spielzeug. Auf jeden Fall beeindruckende Technologie. Wer Interesse hat an diesem oder anderen Projekten, ihr findet die Links in der Seite zu dieser Sendung. Ja, die Ressourcen zu eurem Projekt haben wir weitgehend schon genannt. Es gibt mikrokopter.de, das Wiki, dann gibt es ein Forum dazu. Gibt es noch, unabhängig von Mikrokopter jetzt allgemein, zu der Technik Ressourcen, die ihr da erwähnenswert findet? Habt ihr irgendwelche Webseiten, die jetzt so über Technik, Kubschrauber, Technologie, was nicht die Komponenten oder so besonders viel Auskunft gibt?
Wir können ja mal ein paar Links zusammensuchen und tun die mit bei dir auf die Seite.
Ja, klar, aber da fällt euch jetzt so aus dem Stand nichts ein.
Wie gesagt, das XUFO Forum, das ist www.xufo.de.
Was wir schon erwähnt haben. Okay, alles klar. Dann kommt das irgendwie alles in die Links. Dann denke ich, dann haben wir es. Vielen Dank Ingo und Holger für die ausführliche Darstellung des Themas. Bitte schön. Vielen Dank auch für das Zuhören. Das war Chaosradio Express 106. Wie immer die Aufforderung, kräftig zu kommentieren, bei uns im Blog. Oder wenn ihr Fragen habt, dann könnt ihr in Ausnahmefällen auch mal eine Mail schicken an chaosradioaccc.de. Ansonsten, wenn ihr euch für das Mikrokopter-Projekt interessiert, wie schon erwähnt, mikrokopter.de, dort findet ihr eine ganze Menge Sachen, lustige Videos, die ich nochmal nahelegen kann. Das ist schon ziemlich beeindruckend, insbesondere diese ganzen Autonomexperimente und natürlich vor allem auch diese coolen Flüge mit der Videobrille. Tolle Sache. Ja, dann sagen wir mal ordentlich Tschüss.
Tschüss und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.